hello hi how's it going everybody
I'm currently streaming right now for
reasons that are very unknown to me I am
a little sick today as people get in
here I'll just start spouting about my
life and how I'm just talking to myself
alone in a room and a camera and that's
a totally normal circumstance that I can
accept in my existence oh there I am I
see myself hello how's it going guys so
I'm streaming today yes indeed I am
haven't seen anybody joined just yet but
hopefully oh there we go hi hi guys
how's it going fire Knight Hayden isle
sorcerer choosing galaxy happy girl
dan you should end any how're you guys
doing
welcome to an impromptu stream after I
get back from pax so that I can kind of
decompress after my almost two weeks
stay away from home and being trapped in
the snowstorm so hope youthfully you
guys are doing pretty good and hopefully
you guys can hear me pretty well oh
hello everybody
hi guys oh yeah good news yeah the
stream just started Oh Frick yeah I know
how long am I gonna be streaming I have
no idea prawn not very long because like
I said I'm sick but thankfully for the
first time in a long time
being sick has not robbed me of my voice
I have the flu with whether that's good
or not whether that has to do with me
rolling around in the snow or not I'm
not entirely sure maybe maybe that's it
but I'd like to think that it's not so
I'm a little sick but that doesn't mean
that I can't talk to you guys because
like the other choice was to try to
record a video and I just don't think I
have the energy for it but I think I do
have the energy for a really mellow
stream where I get to talk to you guys
and chat about this pax which was a fun
one it was a really fun one oh yeah I
know this chat is just way fast but you
guys are still I can still see some
stuff so it's good
I know lots of comments so how you guys
been I've been pretty good mostly just
relaxing the past few days we got in
back in LA just yesterday and I was able
to kind of veg out for a little bit
longer I'm taking a lot of medicine you
know it's it's legitimately the flu even
though I got my flu shot this year so it
must be a strain that they don't even
know I still blame Ethan as patient zero
going into pax he was sick before he
came in two packs but that's beside the
point
so yeah hope you guys are doing well
this particular pax is interesting
because when we went to Boston we didn't
even we didn't really we didn't go just
for Boston we went for many other things
and we went for to go up in Maine so so
that Ethan could visit his family and so
that we could see Maine a lot of those
pictures that I was posting on Instagram
and Facebook and Twitter with that
lighthouse those are from Maine so we
got in Monday and we took the train the
next day up to Maine and then came back
down for pax and then we were supposed
to leave pretty soon after but then the
blizzard came in and canceled flights it
wasn't even that bad the blizzard but it
was pretty good sided has gone hey yeah
this chat is cool yeah i andre moreno
hello guys I can't see some things so
you guys you guys are not you guys are
not lost on me so is this unlisted it
shouldn't be unlisted but it's probably
a secret because you guys managed to
find it and that's pretty good so what
I'm gonna do here as you guys may have
guessed I'm gonna play a little more
oxygen not included ever I know you guys
are probably sick of it by now because
I've been posting nothing but that since
I've been away but I've been obsessed
with this game like
I have no stock in this game or like I
have no ownership of it it's just
legitimately good and it recently came
out with an update for the thermal
upgrades so everything that you saw
beforehand was me just starting to play
it the first nine hours of me playing
this game were those 12 episodes that
you guys saw so in that time and in the
time that I've been in Boston I've been
playing this game pretty much non-stop
ever since I've logged over a hundred
hours in it already which is astonishing
and this most recent update that came
out I only just started dabbling with it
and I thought that I could talk with you
guys while also playing this good one so
if you guys want to help me name my
little guys actually you know throw out
a random number one through ten throw
out a random number one through ten and
we're gonna play a little game I might
screw myself over here because I'm not
gonna be able to get good guys that I
want to pick but throw me out a random
number and I'm gonna i'ma pick one at
random and then I'm gonna click this
that same number of times and then
hopefully it's not the worst thing in
the world so okay alright I'm seeing six
all right six for the first one one two
three four five six small bladder
interior decorator vomiter okay not bad
an artist and a scientist good learning
alright what else we got nine okay eight
nine okay gasps true phobia grease my
hey these aren't bad I'm all about the
vomit errs see that I I've actually
learned a lot about the game and before
this patch there was um there was a new
way 20 okay 20 sure yeah alright one two
three four five
18 19 20 hey what do we got yokel and
fibia sting curring well not many good
stats here but at least they're all
vomitus so the funny thing was I'm gonna
name this one our name you mark I'm a
name you Wade
I'm a name you Bob let's see okay
that's sound good oh are you a girl okay
I'm sorry all right
my name you Amy yeah Katherine there we
go okay I'm gonna call you Wade there we
go all right so the funny thing about
this game is that I I really played the
crap out of it I played all the
different ways to play oh thank you
everybody for the the number suggestions
you guys are awesome and you can you can
cool it on the numbers now doesn't no
need anymore
and now no one even knows why numbers
are being thrown up but there was a way
to play this game so that you could you
could get water because the biggest
problem about this game before this new
patch was getting water now the biggest
problem in this game is playing long
enough before you get drowned with water
from these unlimited geysers that shoot
nothing but water and steam everywhere
and it's horrifying because I've seen
some people in cycle 400 of the new
update and they're just like everything
is just an ocean but there's a lot of
changes but let me get back to what I
was saying before so the new the new way
to play brings about or the old way to
play was to have your colony be this
horrible prison where everyone was at
maximum stress and everyone was a
vomiter and so you would do nothing but
make him horribly sick and then you
would just you'd make him horribly sick
and stressed to the point where they'd
just be puking you have no bathrooms
they would just be [ __ ] all over the
place but he would collect all the
polluted water from that and then boil
it to purify and then you'd have water
and that was like the
only way to get water he was horrifying
but it worked you know it legitimately
worked and that was kind of like that's
what I really appreciated about the
genius of this game was that you could
have these to play and yet it worked
like you would legitimately work you
would somehow someway it would actually
legitimately work and that was what was
horrifying about it but that's what I
loved about the game because of how
in-depth it was because as I was
learning more you get to the more
detailed levels of the game like you'd
learn about phase changes so everything
here has different phase just like the
real world but not quite whereas water
can freeze and it can evaporate and when
you're purifying contaminated water
which is now called polluted water you
can boil it and that would clean it into
just normal water and it would
precipitate when it turned into a steam
and then condensed back up and so
temperature became a very important
thing and even more so in this new
update that they've got here makes sense
so if you're wondering why I'm starting
over from the last episode is because I
saw a few people asking that it's
because there was um there was there was
the new update and all of my previous
save files are our bunk so I don't have
those anymore and what that means is I'm
just kind of on my own so so what I'm
going to do now is um I'm basically just
digging out materials that I'm gonna
need going into this game so that's a
bad idea that's gonna flood me I want to
do it though so yeah so basically it's
just it was just a matter of time until
everything would go to horrible horrible
mess
so there's a lot of ways that you can
play like in the beginning now but now
there's a glacier biome and the glacier
is very cold so these are the normal
temperature but I've already got like a
little bit of cold spilling through here
so it's just got to fight everything
it's it's really it's really interesting
just the amount of detail
they put into this game and the amount
of detail that they've made and I
literally just can't stop playing like I
know how to play very well now well very
well now I know how to play but even
this new update is throwing me because I
had some really bizarre worlds and I was
living and trying to struggle through
and it just was not working very well
for me I'm actually gonna get this medal
because I need it let me cancel this for
now so yeah so if that's that's just all
there was to it like he's just a
constant struggling oh that's gonna be
handy I don't know if that's gonna
delete any of the water though it looks
like the the waters about to break
through this area here because sometimes
water in terms of pressure and that's
part of the nightmare scenarios talking
about with geysers it's pretty bad but
um it can I can't really mess you up and
it's no bueno oh I forgot about a
bathroom I'm talking too much all right
what do we got here take of that take
your craps over there so yeah so anyway
I'll talk more and more about this when
I get to because obviously me talking to
you guys right now is meaningless
without context so I'll get to it as it
goes on but I wanted to talk to you guys
about packs and what I was doing
recently during packs and why we were
down there for so long and and the
blizzard and all that and what that got
in the way of and all that jazz and
yadda yadda yadda but it was fun it was
a really fun year and mostly it was
because of the panel that we did like I
had a really good time at the panel
because it allowed us to oh yes he had
broke through there
oh no that hatch is gonna die uh and
he's dead okay so it allowed us to do a
lot of really cool stuff that we
wouldn't normally do it and one of those
things was the panel that we got to do
and I had been doing panels for a while
but this is the first one that we
planned out not really planned out I
kind of did last-minute
thirty minutes prior to the show
planning up but we put some extra effort
into it because we knew that we were
going to do the improv
oh and I I see some people are confused
if you're just joining us I'm doing a
stream because I'm sick I have the flu
I literally have the flu fun story but
my voice is not gone so I'm doing a
little stream so that I can talk to you
guys and get some feedback
[Music]
I've heard of sunset overdrive I don't
know if I'm gonna play that one can you
put oh yeah I'm sorry yeah my face is
locking up the blocking of the other
stuff there so let me just flippy-flippy
flip my camera right there there we go
that's better is that better okay sorry
about that so so oh no don't eat my
metal you little you little bastard
you little bastard don't do it anyway so
that guy's gonna do his thing well that
was when did that happen
Oh pride pressure from the oxalate I
don't know I have no idea where these
things but anyway
what was I talking about sorry I'm sick
I'm actually quite sick yeah yeah no I'm
fine though I can stream though because
streaming doesn't take a lot of effort
and I'm just gonna kind of meander my
way through it and and if I wasn't
streaming I would literally be sitting
playing this game anyway so it's not
it's not that bad for me I'm actually
having just a fine time here all that
poor guy know whatever I don't care he's
a little he's a little jerk so as with
any game you start off by
a research station and all that so yeah
de yada yada not important was I talking
about
I'm so I'm sorry my brain is scrambled
eggs Larry right now
oh yes obnoticus obnoticus is gonna be
coming back that was one of the first
things I was supposed to do um he's been
gone for so long because I've been away
and haven't been able to record it I've
got some plans that I'm gonna do first
of notic I'm going to be building a base
down in the lava zone which is going to
be very difficult to do because I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to get enough
resources down there so I'm probably
gonna have to make a run back up to the
surface and bring it down but my
objective is to eventually kill the the
sea dragon Leviathan not whether or not
that's possible I honestly have no idea
but it doesn't mean that I'm not gonna
try to do it so that's gonna be my
primary objective over there and I know
some people are gonna be upset me and me
killing these Mele woods but I don't
care oh my god I'm not doing at this
point so while I do all this [ __ ]
here you guys can you guys can enjoy me
rambling about packs um so yeah the live
show you where we're doing a touring
show if those of you guys who saw the
panel video and for those of you guys
who've got to the point in the panel
where we were doing the announcements
for that we are doing a touring live
show and I'm really excited about it
because it means the one we get to
travel more and we get to see more you
guys and to it's just something
different to do like for me and my
friends to get together the ones that I
don't get to see very often the ones
that I only really get to see at a
convention or something like that so
it's it's really nice for me to be able
to do that I it's really nice it's
really nice to kind of have this reason
to push ourselves and try something new
and especially with the live show format
and the surprises that we have in store
in case you guys didn't know it's going
to be a choose your own show style of
show because
IIIi don't want to sound out pity about
it and I'm not trying to put anyone
elses touring stuff on like on blast
here but what I wanted to do from it is
I wanted to do more than just travel and
qai I did want I want just just as the
same I wanted my panels to be
fundamentally different than the panels
that people have seen the best I want my
live show to be just a little bit
different than what people have seen in
the past and you know I want to be able
to show that I can do something cool
with a show whereas before you know I'm
not saying that like other shows where
they just go around and meet people are
bad because once again that gives an
opportunity for you guys to meet your
favorite creators in that capacity but
just for me and my own satisfaction I
wanted to do something big because like
a date with markiplier inspired it you
know just because I love the idea of you
guys having choice and you guys having
an impact on what we do and you guys
influencing what we do that really
really appeals to me I just think it's a
cool concept so to bring that to life it
just means a lot to me it just means
that we like we have this outlet with
you guys in this dialogue with you guys
and it means that you know we we we can
reach out and we can actually you know
get to know you guys as who you are
while we discover who we are and that's
really cool so anyway what I'm going to
do is I'm going to try to get some
questions here from you guys if you got
any questions for me ask him now because
I just kind of wanted to go about that
what's up with your voice mark my voice
is fine like I'm just talking quietly
cuz I'm sick once again have the flu
that's not going anywhere
so I just kind of got to deal with what
I got there but doing pretty good just
trying to have a a chill day
[ __ ] did you eat my poop or is that to
do eat the poop did you eat the poop did
you eat the poop in there that's amazing
um this game this game's called oxygen
not included I've been playing it
forever now because I have no life and
this is all I do
let's see coming to Florida we don't
know exactly where we're going we just
know when we're going up beginning of
June is when the the tour is set to
start we're gonna try to hit like four
or five cities first and then we're
gonna try to move on outside of that
what that means is we have opportunities
to come all over the United States and
maybe down the road international but we
have to I have to prove myself first
because I have to I have to know I have
a good show before I take it all over
the world you know so there's kind of
like a an initial like soft run where we
hit a few cities and then we do the big
like multi multi location tour hop all
over the place as efficiently as you can
on a budget because like you know I
don't want to be there's gonna be a
whole bunch of us there's gonna be five
of us you know performing and then
there's other people that help out with
the show for props and whatnot and
moving this stage around and all the set
pieces so it's a lot of people involved
so I just want to make sure that it's
you know you know it's it's good and
done well and done right and doesn't run
itself into the ground so that's my
objective for that but pax was also cool
just because it got to see all my
friends again and then you know I got to
see you know a bunch of games that are
coming up soon I also got some early
demos to some games and I think you guys
are really gonna like because they're
just plain old cool and I think I think
the
they're gonna be really fun because of
this packs especially I only got to walk
this show for a little bit because I
don't know security concerns the
enforcers actually don't want me walking
around all that much so I am constrained
to just where I am but it was so good to
be able to get down there when I could
and see all the cool new games that are
coming out and and like I know people
have been saying some mixed things about
Mass Effect Andromeda but I'm still
gonna play that I'm not gonna do a let's
play or a livestream of that but for my
own personal reasons I I love the Mass
Effect series and I owe it to myself to
be able to play that so that's exactly
what I'm gonna be doing and it sounds is
I don't know I'm just excited about all
of it I'm excited about this year I'm
excited about what's coming in the next
few years on I'm just you know I'm just
excited it may not seem like I'm excited
cuz once again I am sick but I am
excited don't get me wrong
very excited what am I doing here I've
completely forgotten what I'm doing
where am I going
what's happening can you play team five
Faudree fugly asks can you play team
fortress or overwatch again um I could
kill him that hats he was eating all the
poop alright fine then you do you um I
would love to I haven't been able to
play overwatch in a long time like like
like a long time oh someone asked what's
what's what's up with my headphones
um Katherine's borrowing my normal
headphones so I had to bust this out of
my bag still haven't managed to unpack
everyone's still unwinding I'm still
trying to get better from all this
can't dig you've got plusted digging and
you can't dig what a loser
alright fine then I'll take you you're
fine
oh man plus twelve learning ooh but huge
decor expectation oh boy and destructive
- I don't normally take destructive
people but that is the most learning
I've ever seen in my life I'll try to
keep her relatively you know not uh not
this and that's why I'm doing interior
decor because I'm actually trying to
make this place nice instead of being a
giant [ __ ] which is usually because
back when I was just making him all
vomit everywhere you know it was a fun
time having everybody - spewing out
their guts through the entirety of my
base everything was filled with
contaminated oxygen great time everybody
had a lot of everybody loved life
everybody had a great time everybody was
doing it wonderfully okay so what I'm
gonna do here is I'm going to actually
cancel these for now because I wanted
them to focus on the future which is
what I'm going to build here so I'm
going to build out down there that's not
gonna be the permanent place where that
is but it's just for now and then I
cannot think my brain is just dead how
am i doing
you know what I'm gonna make that the
permanent place where it is I like
symmetry for some stupid reason in my
[ __ ] I just don't want them to have
to walk very far but this is gonna be
like my my carbon dioxide trap so that I
can get all that stuff let's see did I
get a new mic no I'm just uh I'm just
live streaming so I've got this other
I've got this program running to
compress my audio live that's why you
may hear the occasional click and pop
it's not because anything's wrong it's
is because the way the software works
sometimes I can't keep up with it
yeah I know Gossman I know you're
stressed well why don't you just
research and then get it over with build
another one of these why don't you gosh
darn it I must speed it up cuz I'm going
a little slow for this normally I like
to take my time with it but I can go
faster nope not that one
see we got water there but I'm also
gonna get access to the water source
here so yeah any other questions
what about my game my other game like I
said I had a save game before this one
but the only problem with that one is
that was prior to the update and the
save games don't transfer wool I keep
futzing with my hair and I mess it up
even more and more every time that's
nice bull cut I'll deal with that one so
I had when the update came about I have
to start a new one so that um you guys
can like I can actually keep going with
it so I had to make a new one I know I
had another save game Oh Gossman with
the research such learning okay come on
guys hurry this up I got a build I gotta
build this [ __ ] we gotta we gotta get
oxygen in here
you dick holes oh god I made it
asymmetrical hey there's so much jeez
bad I think there's gonna be anything -
fine - in the middle yeah no work I'll
do that cuz I'm a stickler for symmetry
I don't know why okay we'll do that
it's a bit excessive but you know what
it is can you make these faster
prioritize please Shaboom Shaboom
Shaboom so anyway yes go into the I know
the jobs menu I know about that I I
would do that but I've only got four of
them right now so I'm not particularly
worried although I'm gonna make you're
gonna be the only artiste in here Wade
oddly enough Wade is the artistic type
in this one and ordinarily like yeah I
know I could specialize the building and
the digging but I don't feel like it I
just don't feel like it I'm very bored
with my life so I'm gonna do that
ah good yes decor mmm yes quite that's
why I didn't want that like that because
I can't make it to across from there
well looks like I'm gonna be blowing
everything up that's okay
best to spend my days destroying what
I've created as opposed to making anew
that's my favorite thing to do yeah okay
we'll get to that in a second yep I know
I know I know I know I'm I'm just that
stupid
alright so now that we got that underway
I should help us out
all right once they get those I don't
want to trap them down there so anyway
what was I talking about don't remember
I'm sick I'm sick I have the flu in case
you guys were just joining me I have the
flu and maybe to do with me being
outside and an idiot build these you're
gonna have people are gonna [ __ ]
themselves and then Gossman is gonna be
passed there we go that's more like it
all right so now that we got that there
we go
it's just prioritize this one here
destroy that there we go now we're doing
better so the reason I did that [ __ ]
was because I wanted to get to straight
across like this what I usually do is I
put the stress tables right here after I
moved that one I'm an [ __ ] is just a
frickin idiot all the time every single
day of my life I'm a goddamn idiot go
for it go faster you Maroons
I need to make I need to make crops
sooner so dumb what are you guys doing
we talking about we're doing a live
stream here is this live well that's a
shame
see you have the flu - I'm sorry for
everybody out there that has a flu get
your flu shots I got my flu shot but
it's you know it's hard to stay healthy
when you're in the face of literally
thousands of pathetic invention from all
over the world with various different
strains of whatever have you coming at
you from all sides so I can't really uh
you know I can't really say that I
didn't want to stay healthy way
sometimes sometimes it just goes that
way oh well what can you do nothing so
what is happening there what are you
doing what are you doing I don't know
what the hell is going on there's dead
there's a few bugs and quirks with this
build
I know I'm not an idiot don't worry I
don't I appreciate your concern but I'm
well aware that I'm I'm a particularly
intelligent individual I'm so smart
put me on our I am very smart that's
where I want to be you know but anyway
no yeah the new video oh yeah people are
wondering
so the question of the day apparently is
was I really naked in that video and you
want to know the answer yes not in front
of everybody else of course but in the
bathtub yeah I was butt naked uh-huh if
you don't know what I'm talking about
check out the new video just for PC
probably for now it's in alpha but ply
they made don't starve so I would not be
surprised if if this came to Mac because
I'm pretty sure don't starve was cross
platform in terms of Mac and PC and then
I don't know if it was on consoles or
not I can never remember that stuff but
uh it was pretty good alright Gossman
how's that doing for your decor is
alright for you
you okay barely this bossy person all
right well they're gonna benefit from
I'm gonna have beds here and the benefit
of having this over here is actually I
can make they made this standard with
this [ __ ] now I can actually put ration
boxes over here and then refrigerate
food for no power and that's actually
very beneficial because that means that
I don't
to have giant batteries that are causing
a bunch of heat I actually don't need to
do anything there I can just make this
like that and then extend this out and
then I'll prioritize this link um this
way when they go do their thing after
they go to bed apparently yes Gossman
please relax that's the one I definitely
need to relax cuz destructive people
such a quick learner do a violin solo I
can't do a violin solo but I got my
guitar here sorry I got the body egg flu
I got my sweet guitar here this is my
new baby I'm very excited about this
when I haven't played it in a while cuz
I've been away from it it's a Jackson
Jackson soloist
I I forget which one it is but it's so
cool I love that I love the matte finish
on it
it's it's pretty standard looking you
know style of guitar but it just I love
the simplicity of it like minimalism is
my thing and not a that this is exactly
minimal with stuff here but um I just
think it's a really cool guitar I was
using a an Epiphone before and not that
this is like not that a new guitar makes
me play any better but it was too bulky
it was like that was a an acoustic slash
electric her no it was a semi acoustic
hollow body electric guitar and that was
cool but this is my new baby because I
so light it's well-balanced I know I
don't know much about guitar brands so I
can't say if if Jackson is a great brand
put this was well reviewed I like the
way it feels it's so I can't play cuz
it's not plugged in obviously it's
electric guitar not that I'd be able to
play it well anyway
I'm not don't worry I'm not I'm not an
expert guitar player that's and that's
for damn sure but but I have it and I'm
still learning so that's good I will get
better about that very soon okay but
anyway now that this is in the cold here
I can put food boxes here and then they
will be refrigerated they will be
refrigerated while they're out there and
then I don't need to worry about this
one because I can just get rid of that
one I also need to keep digging because
I am running low on hello
I'm running low on food I I forgot I was
supposed to plant stuff and done Oh an
artiste a a mouth-breather no never get
mouth breathers they literally suck up
twice as much oxygen they will kill you
cooking athletics construction learning
can't dig it can't dig you know what
okay alright then okay so I'm gonna hold
it at five pretty much five is my limit
for right now I don't want more than
five I just I really really don't want
more than five because five just leads
to more problems in the long run five
will eventually five will eventually
make you dead is more than five
especially right-of-ways is the kind of
thing that just like instantaneously
kills you and I don't want to do that
am i doing here no idea yeah that's a
good fun Wow way to go you had you were
you were four four five and then you're
really crocked it up oh no guy forgot to
sit Ellie Ellie you goddamn idiot screw
you Ellie
alright whatever at least Gossman is
doing ok ok so those are built over
there so I can get rid of this and then
these can be the primary food sources so
in the in the initial phase one I'm
going to plant things as soon as they
frickin clear this out I'm not going to
do that watch your [ __ ] as soon as
they clear this out I'm also gonna dig
this cuz there's some more oxalate there
I'm gonna be digging for more stuff and
you can see buried objects by looking
over here you see this little crack here
that means there's something down there
now that may be a seed but it also could
be just plain food which is always nice
so that's where I'm gonna be digging
next I'll just dig up and try to clear
that out what else I'm gonna do is I'm
going to I'm gonna kind of sealing this
off and I can't can't do that I just
wanted to create like a wall so that I
didn't have to pump oxygen throughout
the whole building can you guys just can
you guys just do something please I
guess there's some good stuff over there
I could just do that yeah I'll do that
alright get ready for the big dig guys
there there there
no don't do that just for the structural
sake and efficiency go do that in this -
I know not enough oxygen I'm well aware
of this
well oh yeah you can't dig I keep
forgetting that you're such an idiot
alright let's just build a ladder right
here like that
there we go and that's the good stuff
there we go
all right so what is happening huh it's
midnight there well why are you watching
this live stream I I was fighting
fighting out people were like you're
live streaming how did you go to bed I'm
like go to bed this live stream is not
worth it it's not gonna stay after this
one
you know we know how all right so
they're gonna they're gonna find
eventually they're gonna find some [ __ ]
down there
where's combat attack it kill it dead
get its meat delicious all right you
guys
why is this not a priority here get that
up get that up there we go
alright any more food see this is what
you're looking for you're looking for
these mock roots so muck roots are
basically they're the plant with their
this plant
buried mockery so those are buried on
the surface so you want those because
it's just free food so when you have
those it's good for you
gonna make this part I know I keep I
keep abusing the prior whoa hey good
idea more food for me
sweet my guys are feeling pretty pretty
easy right now alright so 21 that's
pretty good I'm gonna build the pockets
I don't know call me cultivatable
swelling once really you know what I'm
gonna do this then we're gonna do this
there we go that's gonna give me some
good stuff so anyway yes what huh
you guys were saying something why did
you guys not finish this because I have
no dirt that's why but I'm gonna get
dirt stop being so sexy damn it okay
I've done I stopped that about five
years ago yeah am I going to pax
Australia yeah um I don't know if I'm
going to be doing a whole lot of
international travel this year for
various reasons but also just because
it's it's it's just stressful to go like
a long long distance it's really it
takes a lot out of you like it takes a
lot out of you so just to be able to do
that is is you know it's it's a to go
international anywhere it's just like
it's a it's a slog you
have to do like a lot of planning and
preparation for that so just to start on
that is oh it's it's it's in depth so uh
but you know it's it's rewarding too it
is not bad in any capacity little more
muck hurts thank you for that i I really
abused the digging system the priority
system by the way I know I'm impatient
but this is necessary because we're just
about to like we're not able to breathe
we kind of need like a lot of oxygen
here these guys just aren't providing
there we go that's more like that's a
little better okay so they got that I'm
reachable okay all right we're doing
better now what why is this game amazing
um I don't know I don't know what it is
it's got a long way to go like the more
I've played it the more I realize that
it's lacking a lot of stuff but also the
more I realize that for what it has for
being an alpha it's really amazing like
legitimately this game is pretty
incredible and I'm just like astonished
by what they're able to accomplish here
and what they've managed to accomplish
in such a short time it's it's it really
is just oh man I am blown away why the
the ridiculous amount of detail that
they've put into this oh okay so there's
a little there's a little there's been
some changes to the crops you know so
I'm gonna start out with meal would just
because it's easy to grow and it grows
pretty quickly but I'm gonna move on to
other stuff just because the bristle the
brittle thing because it's it's more
beneficial in the long run to do that
because now the meal would don't
guarantee a seed to you once it's done
growing and unless you want to bug it
out and you want to dig it up after
there's only one harvest remaining which
if you do that it's fine I guess a
little Chiti but you know to their own
you got to do what you gotta do to
survive right I made people vomit and
now I'm gonna draw the line I made
people vomit and [ __ ] their pants and
I'm gonna draw
line it I would draw the light digging
up a plant just before it's done but
that's that's where I draw my but I'm
also drawn the line there because the
bristle the brittle the brittle Blum /
the bump man I'm sick by the way did I
mention that I'm sick the brittle Blum /
the brim plumber the Blum the bristle
block Brit bristle blossom that was it
the bristle blossom it
it likes symmetry god I shouldn't stop
that the brittle blossom is is quite
quite better now it wasn't as good
before but now it's much much better
just because it allows for a lot more
versatility in the temperature range
that it can survive in which allows you
to have more food over time I am slowing
down I am very not well but I'm gonna
keep going I'm not gonna do a very long
stream don't worry I'm gonna I'll
probably be uh I'll probably be packing
up my bags pretty soon here but but it's
it's it's the flu sucks that's what I
want to say the flu sucks flu real bad
feel real bad flute playing so pretty
bad
I cannot for the life of me remember I
gotta get rid of this contaminated
oxygen which is why I'm getting
sanitation services so I can get the air
deodorizer come to Israel again
International trips are gonna be gonna
be tough for me so right now I'm just
gonna be focusing on in the United
States I will rest don't worry I'll rest
I've slept like 12 hours last night and
I'm taking plenty of medicine this is
not hard for me to do this is hard for
me to think which is why I'm sitting in
case you didn't know this is normally a
standing desk and I I stand that a lot
and that's it's really good for me to
make for these well I'm standing but
standing when sick is not the most fun
thing in the world so I'm going to just
relax take it down a notch and just talk
with you guys here it's good [ __ ]
no I'm not gonna do that that's because
I made this into the into the trap for
carbon dioxide okay they're doing better
on oxygen by the way so that's good to
know
long term for this I got to get my food
supply going obviously these six are not
gonna be enough I'm going to need more
but that's why I'm gonna build out this
way
I'm just gonna try to drop this down
here yeah that'll be fine so I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna drop this down yeah just
like that get out of here get what are
you doing hatch gotta get kill it get
its meat eat it's delicious meat dad
okay you're dead I see they're building
that they're powering that that's good
good good annoys me alright so yeah I
have the flu how's it going good did you
guys like the new video did you guys
like the the winter is coming official
trailer if i ever post a video if i ever
post a trailer for something legitimate
that i'm doing you guys will never
believe me cuz I put official trailer on
all my fake trailer videos I'm the boy
who cried trailer Last of Us part 2 is
that confirmed is that coming out I
can't even remember so how did that sort
of Luke yeah this is slow mode yeah I
can see it though I've got I've got
special special privileges and I'm able
to see things yeah you liked it yeah
yeah I was funny yeah we were we were
stuck and I was I was committed to
making something very stupid so I did
exactly that I'm very good at making
that whole stupid thing oh man I've got
my base is to open right now I've got a
problem in that regard I'm trying not to
spread the oxygen too thin but I
got to the polluted ice there we go
gosh it's about damn time Wade getting
together alright so I'm going to make
the decor real nice down here that's not
what I wanted to do can you not do that
blah what happened to clicking and
holding huh oh I can't because the crops
I forgot about that dang it okay so
that's just gonna suck how's the decor
over here it's okay I've got floor
clutter and that's what's problem but
Gossman is doing okay so I'm not gonna
worry about that come to Finland I don't
know about that no I don't think I'm
gonna be going to any Popcaan again I
I'm really trying to back down from
conventions in general and more on these
like the shows and like actually setting
up meet and greets not that I don't like
the conventions I'm still gonna go to
the paksas east and west but just as far
as like as far as like everything else
goes like I just want to keep it keep it
relatively tame for my own sanity
because I want to make other good videos
for you guys like a day with markiplier
and then we've got other stuff in the
work for dates too
I know you guys loved April Fool's last
year and don't worry I got you covered
I got you I got you if you think I don't
got you I got you don't worry about it I
got you so that's gonna be pretty
exciting when that comes about
there's stuff I know pretty much all a
chat right now is you guys telling me to
go places but don't worry about it
I really I really would love to be able
to take you guys advice on where to go
but I can't that's not the way I have to
work it so what I got to do is I just
got a planned it out accordingly go to
the places where we all as a group want
to glow and then where we know where the
majority of you guys can get to and can
go to so that's how we're gonna plan it
out there other than that I plan to stay
home for a good long while because
number one kind of snick and number two
kind of like being home not that you
know LA I always good enough and I'm
starting to like it more and more but uh
those are the places to that I want to
go I want to be able to go to so that's
good
yeah one second I gotta get this all set
up
Oh new duplicate unless you're amazing
oh my god you know for having three
positive traits you don't have them any
stats and your destructive
mouth-breather can't build
nah I'm sticking with five no thank you
no thank you
I need beds for everybody we're gonna
put the beds I should have thought this
better leave you out house has to go I'm
gonna move that over here yeah I'm gonna
do that because I want the beds over
here for the most part my build
different compost heap right yeah like
this and then I'm gonna put a deodorizer
right there
I know the deodorizer right there and
then get rid of these eventually oh no
he's over eating see temperature
actually is a very important thing now
that you have to concern yourself with
so eventually I'm gonna destroy all this
stuff because I can't have heat
contained like this you have to let it
vent up which is something that I'm
definitely going to do eventually
eventually so yeah oh no I look over at
Chad the first thing I see is come to
here now no enough of those give me some
more questions you got me for a limited
amount of time don't be don't be
blasting me with those things oh I am
tired I'm sick I may have mentioned that
before
what am I playing I'm playing oxygen not
included which is the news game by don't
starve I've been playing a ton of it and
I can't stop playing so as I'm getting
farther and farther you can see you're
like I'm starting to explore the
surrounding and it's just kind of it's a
lot of uh it's a lot of glacier like a
long glacier hey buff tease how you
doing oh and there's this new there's
this new plant called a thimble Reed
which if you want to go to the hot and
cold areas you need that stuff because
you need to be able to make clothes for
your duplicants and you need like
heat-resistant clothing to be able to do
some of the more difficult explorations
right so don't destroy these did you
finish the research yet god damn it come
on
Gossman what did I get you here for you
learn yourself
oh they're wounded I forgot about that
balderdash balderdash okay so I'm gonna
disassemble these cuz I'm not gonna need
them there
get those sweep of that thank you
let's see some people are asking for
night in the woods his fight story about
night in the woods I actually I download
that game when it first came out like
the day came out and I was like oh maybe
there's gonna be a who's gonna be good
let's play so I did die I did I did a
long episode of it and and then I I I
didn't really like it it's I know that
probably upset some people like and not
like the game is bad I'm not saying the
game is bad by any stretch of the
imagination but it wasn't my type of
game to do a let's play of so I'm not
gonna do that one
I actually yeah cuz I I recorded it the
day of or I got it the day of I recorded
it the day of I made a video of it the
day of and I looked at it and I made
like a 45 minute video of it and because
I was playing it to try to get to the
meat of the matter and I was going
through it and and it was it was good it
was an interesting game just not my type
for the let's play you know what I mean
so I may I may finish it on my own but
you know if there's a lesson I've
learned it's uh
when I find a game that that's good but
doesn't that I don't think is gonna be
you know kind of like what I want for my
channel I I learned to let that lie I've
learned my lesson in the past about that
one
yeah it's it's a good it's a good it's a
good game just not for me and not for
the channel and you know what I mean
gotcha I think I've made my point
absurdly unclear okay so what am I doing
here
refrigerated food what was I doing I can
never remember of course I'm right by
the polluted ice grand
and sufficient oxygen generation my left
nipple okay alright so stage to air
deodorizer make that a top priority
hurry up Bob build bigger we are gonna
be doing another charity livestream very
soon I believe it's going to be next
Saturday I'm not a hundred percent sure
about that if things got thrown off
schedule after we we had to we had to be
delayed in Boston so obviously that got
in a way what but we will get to that
very soon so don't worry about that it
is not lost we're definitely gonna do
one this month we've definitely
committed to ourselves to be able to do
that on the monthly basis so that's
something that you guys don't have to
worry about okay so that's about how
like that boopadoo
oops water leftover we'll just have to
mop it up and don't think it's very much
yeah it's tiny mouths water because most
of the waters down there that's good
let's see yeah
did you restart yeah I restarted new
patch new updates new [ __ ] to do new
lots of cool stuff to see okay what are
you guys doing are you guys doing
anything no you're not build beds make
it nice decorum let's see I want to make
this super nice so I've got five beds
total we're gonna have seven eventually
so I can account for that decor put a
painting above each bed sculpting rocks
right there do I don't need sculpting
rocks there that's gonna be more than
enough decor just from those
a little bit I could do I don't know
what I could do I could just make it six
beds just so I could have eventually
eight people yeah I think that makes
more sense it's a good number to have
seventh of your number let's just do it
like this
all right all right how about some of
that hashtag sexy mark that's an old
video sculpt a pee noir well I just have
to build the sculptor and then it's
practically a painting or by itself oh
yeah I need I need a new power system so
we're gonna have the power be over here
because and we're gonna start building
with heavy watt batteries because we
need that so like I mentioned before
there's now cold coming in from this
side so the benefit of that is you can
start putting your hotter stuff like
your batteries and one not actually the
batteries don't create that much heat
anymore which is kind of nice but you
can start putting more cold stuff
towards that end eventually you're gonna
need like the food makers oh I should
make that a galley two three four five
six one two three four or six do you
could do that that's not a bad idea
I like that
mm-hmm so I could make I can make this
the galley and then the food gets put
down there thus it is the food
production area because the food
production area is actually quite hot
these get real hot so you need two of
them generally the meal wood is not
quite in there we've got food to last
though do we have only one person on
earth yeah good good good talking about
sick mark is best mark I hope not
god I hope not I do have a habit of
getting very sassy when I'm sick hey
guys got anything for me to sass because
I'm not opposed to some good
old-fashioned sausage right now I'm SAS
and my cell phone I don't have anyone
else assess what I haven't been doing is
I haven't been paying attention enough
to just be able to kind of like set
everything aside and give them a task to
do I've just been kind of uh running my
own way I'm just gonna let this drain
down too cuz it's a straight channel
straight down this water is just gonna
fall right down there and then I can get
this stuff huh
Oh SAS Ethan he gets enough Seth he gets
plenty of SAS five nights at candy's 3
that is something on my schedule I'm
gonna do that pretty as much as soon as
they get better so don't you worry about
a thing that is definitely gonna happen
Wade's clothing
Wade's clothing is negative 5 I didn't
think that I'd be able to SAS sex the
outfit already what I'm actually gonna
do is I'm probably going to
over here to the compost cuz the compost
should be the only thing that's actually
producing completed up oxygen and I can
put a sculpture there that'll be a
little they'll be marginally better
good job Wade you did it I'm so proud of
you even though you can make art your
outfit still is just terrible just the
absolute worst okay so I'm going to need
heavy wat boink boink boink
the thing about heavy wot and the way
they've changed up power is that heavy
wot is what you need to get higher
wattage so what mano y are were you
Suffolk
why are you over there how in the flying
[ __ ] did you two get there okay I don't
know what the hell happened there huh
how in the flying [ __ ] did those two get
trapped down there how in the how in the
Jim Belushi Oh cuz they were dumb in
there I see watch they're just gonna be
an idiot they're gonna build this
without building their they they have
this terrible habit of building down
like that don't do that don't do that
move up there what are you what are you
doing you stupid idiots
you stupid idiots - oh my god Katherine
these dum-dums they're just trying to
get themselves killed and I have no idea
why don't do that okay crisis averted
it's one way to give me sass and
something sass and you Catherine seasons
anyway sorry about that yeah just
[Applause]
okay that's fine
no yelling when I'm sick I die
unfortunately don't have a P o box I do
long ago back in the yonder year of 20
2013 I can't anymore it's just too much
fan mail not that I don't like fan mail
and and that stuff like I appreciated
but it got to a point where he was
consuming my entire life and then people
were sending me stuff just so it could
get on the video that I made whenever I
got stuff and so that robbed the entire
experience so I would rather you know
and and I don't like getting gifts I'm
not a gift type i I don't celebrate my
birthday very much I don't why are you
running there's no battery attached to
it why are you running why are you
running on that just to get some
exercise I guess I can't really fault
them that's what we do on treadmills all
day every day we just kind of let them
take us on their way so I guess I can't
complain too much I'm gonna prioritize
this stuff because they need access to
that water supply oh there's another one
over I forgot I was I talking about it
no idea I am I am gone right now I have
no brain capacity
[Music]
there's no brand right now what hmm huh
flu for hair for power flu the hair for
greasy sweat at the moon is what I'd
flew the hair for because I'm a bit of a
mess with the flu so that's the kind of
thing that you can count on and not
anything in the way of meaningful
commentary and excuse me I'm about to
cough that's all I needed like a sneeze
I get my cuffs out of the way real good
no go to sleep I slept enough I slept
for 12 hours I know what I need just
like I know I need to walk naked in the
snow for the sake of a video remember
how I said can't remember where I said
it but I I'll do pretty much anything
for what is to keep doing that I need to
give them batteries or they're gonna go
out of their minds come on build
batteries say perfect perfect three
sweet delicious batteries that's the
good stuff
is that enough oxygen for everybody baby
Heidi Davey Davey maybe it is we'll see
what happens so with this new update
water actually is much less of a problem
than it used to be they give you more
water at the start of the game number
one and number two it's it's um it's
easily produced in geysers now I'm
actually kind of hoping that I don't get
a geyser coming my way anytime soon
because that is that is basically the
end of the game for me whenever I get to
a geyser but at least I got thimble
Reed's here and that's pretty good I'm
gonna get that soon but not now
what am i doing I have no idea oh yeah I
need to get that because my meal was
starting to come in so I'm gonna need
that pretty soon so with the meal would
you can make lice bar which is much
better than just letting them eat lice
by themselves because lice is now not a
renewable resource play village was a
play Astra near I don't know unless
there's more stuff to do an Astra near I
don't know if I'd be playing more of
that I'd really have to see what they
have in store because I want I want
there to be more stuff to do an
astronaut an adder of getting to that
point get rid of that that is so ugly I
couldn't let that be made I need to make
I need to make the medical cots again
again I need to make medical cots
because I don't have I don't some people
are injured and when they're injured
number one it used to cause stress I
don't think it causes stress anymore but
when they're injured it just causes a
lot of problems
visit the center of the planet I've
actually been down there in the in the
in my own game and what's interesting is
I'm pretty sure this is how this works I
don't know if one person but there is no
center of the planet you start in the
center of the planet that's just my
understanding I don't know if that's
true but I've been down all the way
south
I've been down all the way to the east
and at the edges is this material called
neutronium and neutronium can't be mined
by any of the any of the duplicates I've
actually broken neutronium and gotten
pieces of it but fat a lot of good that
does anybody but I've gotten neutronium
before and it's interesting because it
like defines the edge of the world it's
like bedrock and minecraft you reach a
point where you can dig any farther or
you're not technically supposed to there
are ways to get bedrock but you're not
supposed to be able to dig it and and
contained within the edges of the world
are pockets of magma so in the edges of
the world there's magma everywhere you
go there's a magma magma and it's very
hot so the whole game is like how long
can you survive
there's no way to survive forever
there's something that's always gonna
kill you and at the end of it all is
like the heat death of the universe it's
entropy you're fighting entropy because
it's hot on the outsides and it's cool
in the middle and it's cold in pockets
but there's always going to be entropy
hot flows too cold it tries to reach an
equilibrium so in this equilibrium that
you have you eventually get to a point
where you can't get it any colder and
survival becomes harder and harder and
harder now to a point there is a bug
right now with this thing called a hydro
fan the hydro fan is extremely
overpowered at
moment it's it's just a load of [ __ ]
it there's a there's a bug with the way
that it interacts with the way that it
interacts with what's it called carbon
dioxide because carbon dioxide will
solidify it won't liquefy Adel's no it
should liquefy but if if someone's
breathing right on top of a Hydra fan
it'll turn their carbon dioxide breath
because they breathe out such a small
amount of it it'll turn that into solid
form or liquid form and then it'll
instantly change back but when it turns
solid it's at like a negative 60 degrees
Celsius so it turns everything around it
negative 60 degrees Celsius - so I had
this one the first time that I was
playing the new update it basically
destroyed my entire base because I could
not get anything warmer anymore it
created like this perpetual cycle of
death for me where everything was always
cold no matter what I did no matter
where I went
everything was freezing and everything
was bad and it was it was really funny
number one it was just really really
funny but I
III still like it was really funny like
I couldn't not laugh at it my whole base
was just freezing to death all my crops
I had space heaters all throughout it I
had batteries pumping microbe mushers
wouldn't make it hot and that was from
those four it's the one hydro fan Nadya
I'm not even talking about and I've
talked about thermal regular I'm talking
about the little fan that they they pump
on their own it's just there was no hope
there was no
there was no hole I'm gonna do this you
can turn these sideways did you know
that I didn't know that before actually
forget that it's just easier to wallet
it was going on where'd everybody go
where'd y'all go where'd you guys go dig
this up to this up to this what's
happening okay whatever
all right what are we out last two oh
hell yeah last two is coming out soon
you can bet your bottom button that I'm
gonna be playing a whole bunch of
outlast too like you think I'm not gonna
be playing outlast - oh my god you're
wrong I'm gonna be doing a video that
every single day like I cannot waive for
outlast - and it's so cool because
there's been a lot of very very high-end
there's been a lot of high-end what'd
you call it triple a horror games coming
out lately with Resident Evil 7 that was
great it's got DLC coming out soon
you've got outlast 2 coming out there
was another horror game that I saw at
PAX I can't remember the name of it but
it was there - god this is so much I
don't want people I don't want more than
one person that can't dig so I'm just
gonna reject these guys
of lancelin site some woman I don't have
food set up for more people yet I got to
get food ready life's a little [ __ ] so
we got our batteries and that's good and
there should be cold good yeah see the
cold is just coming through and now this
is nice and cold so these don't worry
about heat they've got their beds all in
order that one's cold see the weird
thing about the new thermal thing is
something can be cold and then it just
kind of stays that way it's kind of hard
for you to transfer like this compost is
negative five point three degrees
Celsius why I don't know why but it's
turning all the air around it cold it's
weird it's weird okay so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to wall off this like
eventually this is going to be the
defining box that is my base just
because it makes my life easier when
it's boxed in like this is this dug in
here insufficient oxygen still oh that's
barely insufficient it'll be better once
I block it off okay so those are built
so I should have built that there why
didn't I do that that was dumb of me to
do that I'm an idiot why didn't I do
that huh cuz I'm an idiot I just said it
no I sure did didn't I why do I have to
bury locks now I don't know maybe let me
revisit the crazy concept that I am an
idiot I am a very smart idiot I'm an
idiot who could have been an engineer I
am a dumb but anyway it's hard to get
this built because you have to build
above it but they have a start here that
they can build on what what the hell
whoa that's weird
okay that's bizarre
steel door do not translate Hey no one
out there translate this steel door you
keep it just between you and me huh you
keep it between you and me huh do them
three you guys actually want to see it
let's play a Doom 3 I don't know about
that
III don't know I don't know if I'm gonna
want it like that's an old game I love
the game don't get me wrong I love that
in the new Doom I just don't think I'm
gonna play Doom 3 after I played after I
played doom you know on the channel
which I loved I love that that was great
so good yeah I just don't know if I'll
play another one or play Doom 3
specifically I'd play another one if it
came out like don't get me wrong I would
love to play another doom if they've
come out with a sequel for that like
heck yeah I'm all about that just don't
know if I'd be doing that don't know if
I'd be doing that you nailed it
got that good that's funny guys did you
know that I'm funny did you guys know
that I don't think anybody knew that I'm
not gonna be doing a playthrough of
Andromeda I
I love the Mass Effect games I love
those but it's not really something that
I'd want to let's play because that
would sour the experience for me it's a
very personally personally important
game for me because I love the first
three games and I don't even know if in
drama is gonna be good
but I'd still like to play it on my own
to experience it on my own for that
reason
um yeah I don't have a depository I I
don't see the names that people chatting
by the way but I see you guys chatting
and I see the messages um I don't have a
depository for game suggestions I I do
take game suggestions just not here in
chat is not the best place even though
it's I know you guys are talking to me
right now and I can see it it's not the
best place for chats and game
suggestions is in the chat just because
this is very difficult for me to retain
it oh goody
first harvests yes please okay so with
the benefit of this I should create a
backdoor straight in to here maybe I
could just do it straight like that not
post that yeah that would be okay that'd
be acceptable so uh I like I used to
have an email that I would check but you
know even that's harder so the best I
can do is there are people out there if
you guys want to take it upon yourselves
to compile a big list of games that
people are suggesting right now like I
always love the fact that the community
out there you know will help me out when
the time comes oh that's not gonna work
I'm dumb I'm very dumb apparently Wow
I cannot believe I did that oh boy I am
dumb okay so this is what I wanted to do
and then destroy this and destroy these
stupid pieces of crap there so if you
guys want to take it upon yourself
compile a big list post it somewhere
that I can see it create an image like
whatever it is and send the compiled
list as opposed to games by piecemeal
you know that helps me infinitely more
um then shouting into chat would not
that I don't appreciate you guys candor
but you guys you guys you guys are good
I like you but I know this just uh
there's more to be done
you know anyway I have no idea what I'm
talking about who's stressed Gossman why
are you stressed go go get a massage
gasping gasping go go relax and kick
back relax you got you doing great
costume you're doing too good in fact
yeah rimworld I've heard a lot of people
talking about rimworld I I don't know
about much about the game I've been out
of the loop on a lot of games for a
while and I know I know there were some
concerns about me just doing you know
abandoned in games entirely and doing
sketches but that's absolutely not what
I'm gonna be doing because I have so
many games that I want to play in gaming
has always been a core of what I do on
the channel but as far as like doing
sketches of stuff yes of course I want
to do more of those but as far as like
doing Let's Plays I'm always gonna be
doing that so bring on the games like I
got them oh god h1z1 don't give me that
game also hello neighbor
hello neighbor needs substance it needs
some goddamn substance there you know I
need I need some more I need more in my
life for hello neighbor
alright so now we got a back door this
is basically for the microbe mushrooms
to be able to do their thing why are
these not doing their thing we've got
I'm gonna be lice we've got access to
water we've got meal lice why are we not
doing these things I don't know who's
sick oh yes some of you guys are going
slow because you're sick aha Bob Bob
getting bed you're sick
Gausman you're injured go to bed in that
cot I love when they get in the cactus
or somehow they get casts on their
phlegon Armand
burr it's not as good as a rejuvenator
but then again what is alright so I need
to build my research quarter again
because I kind of forgot about it don't
tell anybody but I actually completely
forgot about it all right gasping you're
better who's not better Wade well let's
put Katherine before Wade there all
right let's get some more decor up in
here blow see why not
let's splatter the decor all over the
walls actually let's not splatter the
decor yeah you know we can splatter the
decor over the walls
shabbu ski let's make it real pretty I
love it when there's just nothing but
this painting hopefully in the final
game there's gonna be more than just
this panty because it's just kind of
like the dead eyes staring at you from a
distance look in your soul and they'll
eat your flesh okay so
Finding Bigfoot yes I'm gonna do more
Finding Bigfoot
I wanted to real bad and then I went
away I made the mistake another bad
thing about me playing this game too
much as uh I I meant to record different
games besides this but I just couldn't
stop playing oxygen not included I just
I flip and love this game I love the
game so much and I'm glad that you guys
liked it too I like I would have been
devastated if you guys didn't like this
game cuz I would have I would have taken
it as a personal affront to me have you
guys hadn't liked this game but it's
just so fun look honestly this game is
just pure and simple fun fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
and subnautica yeah I'll get to silica
ash at Freddy's 4 who's suggesting for
that games done
oh yeah for those who just joining me
yes I'm sick I have the flu
just doing a very very relaxed very
gentle live stream right now where I get
to just kind of like chill and do my
thing while talk to you to you guys I'm
just reading ya kazoo kid that's a that
was yeah I just get to chill with you
guys while I talk about the things that
I really enjoy oh yeah I'm supposed to
talk about packs why didn't it why
didn't I do that so oh yeah
outside of pack so going up to Maine and
just seeing around and doing all that
sort of stuff it's been really fun for
me like it's been fun to see these
environments and it's been fun to go
around and do various other things and
didn't I set didn't I set a goddamn air
deodorizer to be built over here because
I was gonna make cuz someone's bed is
not very d'accord and it all depends on
which angle they go at but even so I'm
just gonna make a doden another
deodorizer right there and then replace
this with a frickin sculpting block once
that gets in there was I talking about
though I can'twe get in there Wade your
turn Bob's almost done
wires have a watt
um yes so we went up to Maine and one we
got to see Maine which is kind of a lot
like Ohio it's a bit colder temperature
wise and gets more snow of course but it
was still fun to be able to experience
that and be around those people and be
around just and just be around that type
of a very again see the wooded areas and
you know all that stuff and it was it
was really good and I liked it a lot you
guys everyone healed up I think I think
yes Ellie everyone's healed so yeah it
was good and we took a lot of pictures
while we were up there one of the things
that I found that I enjoy very much like
I enjoy it a ridiculous amount more than
I am more than I ever should is um I
went trampolining look like I went
trampolining and I love rock climbing
like I've told you guys before that I
absolutely love to rock climb and and
that's still true but I went
trampolining and if you don't know what
that is it's literally just a gym where
the floors are all trampoline everything
is cushioned you can still break your
neck on it but it's fun and we were just
jumping around for about two hours
straight and what was great about that
is we it was trying so hard to do a
backflip on a trampoline of course I'm
miles away from doing it on the ground I
don't think I'd have the confidence to
do it anyway but I was trying so hard to
do a backflip that I basically wore
myself down to the bone just bouncing on
a trampoline it was the most fun
exercise I've ever experienced in my
life and I did research on it like it's
really good for you to do exercise
that's just bouncing on a trampoline
because one it's low-impact it's easy on
your joints they use it for astronauts
when they come back instead of running
you know on pavement and gravity they
just have him bounce on trampolines and
you burn like a lot of calories I'm not
saying it's like the the most calorie
burning
as ever but you burn like a surprising
amount of calories just from jumping on
a trampoline because you use your whole
core to be able to stabilize yourself as
you're going backwards and forwards and
jumping all around you use way more
muscles than you think and you're like
squatting with every jump and this is
fun its childlike fun and I've never
gone to a place like that before our
nurses and of course even he's been
going there and he's a gymnast so he's
gonna do flips and stuff but I'm just
barely trying to eat him straight up and
down it's it's just really fun and so if
I were to ever make a gym and no one can
steal this idea I'm it's on livestream
it's officially mine I would make a gym
that's a combination rock wall
bouldering climbing gym and trampoline
gym like I'd have a climbing section and
then trampolines and then you'd have
rock walls and you could climb up and
then jump off into trampolines it would
be it would be the most dangerous place
for a human to go like just from an
injury perspective but even so it'd be
so fun couldn't wait for it I'd be great
it'd be so good I love that so much this
is so fun god it's fun don't know why
it's fun but it is just bouncing around
and being there with my friends do like
that was another big big benefit of it I
like that so much and it is just like it
was a very pure experience whatever you
want to call a pure experience but it
was just it was that it was just yeah I
don't play many console games I know
Oh pray pray is coming out the other the
remake or the sequel to pray I love pray
I played pray awhile back pray pyaari
wise game that was made back in like
2005 or something like that I can't
exactly remember but good game a lot of
potential but a lot of a lot of wasted
potential to because they could have
done a sequel it had some pretty mind
warp
effects in it but it just didn't live up
to the hype or it didn't perform as well
as like the salesman's wanted that too
and you know yada yada yada that's
usually how it goes but um even so like
a prey the next prey is coming out and I
don't know if it's gonna be as good but
I'm still still kind of like holding on
to hope
holding on to the like the meager hope
that maybe I don't know maybe it's gonna
be okay so we'll see about that
oh yeah I wanted to make this into a
furniture yeah this is gonna be the mess
hall basically maybe this should be the
mess hall now I've already got this made
up hello who's there who do we got can't
cook but interior decorator can dig I'm
still not ready for another person yet I
don't know what village is what is that
a vis AG I have no idea what that is I
there's a lot of games that I just
haven't seen much of oh I do want to
play more yandere simulator I've got
this I've got this thing I want to do
with you on dairy simulator because what
it's become is is another thing that I'm
not a big fan of is like just showcasing
new things like every update I would
play on very similar just to showcase
the new thing you could do and I never
really liked that because I never really
played young dairy simulator just to
play it so I'll leave it at like you
guys let me know what you think about it
but I kind of want to do the same thing
I did with subnautica when it went when
I when I left some Nautica I left it
because I was doing that thing I was
doing the thing where I was only showing
you guys the updates are not playing the
game for the sake of the game and then
when I came back to subnautica I played
it with the commitment that I'm just
playing it to play it I'm not playing it
to show you guys what's new I'm playing
it to experience it all of the farming
included
and I have stuck with that and I've
intentionally stuck with that because
it's it's something that's just you know
very important to me so at the same time
with that I also wanted to do the same
thing with dairy simulator you know I've
never played it to play I've always
played it played it for the meme of it
yeah I've never really played it for
anything other than the meme of it so
I'm just kind of curious and kind of
curious if there's anything else like to
be done for that and so I'll see it oh
also blossom seeds have been vastly
improved they still grow in ten cycles
so it takes a long time for them to grow
they regrow in two cycles but they now
produce two berries they take less
fertilizers they can exist in vastly
different temperatures now like wildly
different temperatures like me it's
really really good just the pure variety
that they can they can exist in so I'm
just gonna start planting these all have
them growing you know over time so that
they'll always be there and then I don't
have to worry about it that's
unrelatable gear staring it yeah I'm
doing terribly analogy I have no allergy
I am a doof what have I been doing with
my life I don't even know I don't know
man about I just dig this out but that's
gonna it's gonna cost me a problem then
my water is gonna go here well c'est la
vie let's do this dig that out I need to
dig this down anyway because I wanted to
make another another level down anyway
okay so that's gonna run the water down
I might be able to get it into there it
would take a while but I think I'd be
able to do it I just need to prioritize
this row yeah who recorded me in the
bathtub I can't remember if those a me
or Catherine I think Amy did we took
turns but Amy also helped edit that one
her record that one can't remember
though this been a while huh it's been a
while I mean it seems like it's been a
while but honestly it hasn't been a
while considering that was like that was
Christmas which is not that long ago
really really not that long we go yeah
god it's only March it's been a long
long long long beginning of the year for
me like it's it's been taking its time
getting through this year and that's a
good thing you know obviously it's a
good thing because I'm not you know not
just shooting through my life here but
uh it's also a good thing just because
you know I'm doing pretty I'm doing a
lot of good things I'm doing I'm making
a lot of progress in my life and I'm
making a lot of personal progress in
what I'm what I have been doing and and
I think it's all very good it's just you
know it's III overemphasized the term
I'm doing good you know III obviously
overemphasize that but even so like I am
I'm doing very well and I'm doing a lot
of things that I'm very proud of this
year and it's only just the beginning
and it feels like it's been feels like
it's been a long one and it really has
but uh I'm pretty eager to see what the
future what the future has in store for
me and what I got going on but man it's
been so so my deal now for my workouts
which I've been trying to do every
single day and now that I'm back I'm so
year cuz I've been going out of my mind
not working out because once you get in
a habit you feel really shitty not
working out and I feel really shitty
because I have the flu right now but you
feel really shitty not working out so I
cannot wait to get back into it
now I want to incorporate it going to a
trampoline gym everyday but I know I
can't do that every day ago base is so
fun
God is so fun can I start a Kickstarter
to build my own my own my own trampoline
gym yeah I think I think I'd be that'd
be the ideal for me do you mind you guys
money ole ye olde
Kickstarter for for markiplier
trampoline slash rock climbing gym huh
you guys wanna you guys wanted to that
sounds like the ideal for me I don't
know about you guys but not bad okay so
what am I do is I'm gonna do the shitty
thing I'm gonna dig these up because I
don't want to run out of food yeah
what's my workout routine umm for the
for the most part it's normally like
it's normally an insanity DVD of some
sort so I'll do insanity like usually if
I'm in a hurry I'll do max 30 I'm not
advertising for Beachbody by the way who
makes all this [ __ ] I could care less if
you do it it's way too hard just to
start with but it's easy to do because
just like a 30 minute exercise and you
can do it from home you waste a lot of
time driving to the gym and then driving
back and then showering so I try to
maximize my time which makes it easier
to keep committed to doing it so I tried
to do that I try to do that every single
morning I'm not I'm not doing a lot of
weight lifting so a lot of people who
are like hey you should work out every
single day that's bad for you it's like
I get that but I'm not doing
bodybuilding if your bodybuilding you
know you can't do that every day or you
have to isolate very specific muscle
groups throughout your body to give your
muscles time to regenerate but I mean
I'm trying to build muscle I'm just
trying to get in shape so that's pretty
much what I do I try to go to mix it up
on it because that gets boring like
DVD workout every morning I would get
boring as hell I try to mix it up by
going to the gym to the rock climbing
gym so that I can do something that I
find fun but even that you know you can
get burnt out on it it's kind of
depressing because I used to be really
really good at climbing and my baby
crushers as they were known throughout
the Wild West now I was able to squeeze
with infinite strength but lately it
seems like my own fitness strengths has
turned to baby hands you know like in
Deadpool any there's a little baby hand
yeah that was me trying to climb when I
was getting back into it but still it's
pretty good you know I can't I can't
complain at all I really can't I'm
getting in good shape but man being a
week and a half off of it while I was in
Boston was just hell like hell I felt
like the laziest piece of crap in the
world yeah last of us to hell yeah I'd
love to play that am i wearing green no
unfortunately I don't think I'm wearing
green right now so pinch away I've got a
green water bottle so does that count
maybe
oops there we go harvest this house soon
as Harvest Moon what are you guys doing
why are these guys not doing anything
it's it's it sucks having only five in
the beginning it really does in my
opinion just because just because you
get a lot less done I'm used to having a
base of 10 people 10 people is a good
number I've got 10 tables here I've got
8 cots in total I could eventually get
more so I like having 10 people because
it allows me to do the most work
possible and that's nice and all I don't
know I'm getting 2 up in the meta of
this game but god I just love this game
so much because there's so much cool
stuff to see I've barely scratched the
surface like this whole time I've been
playing and I have no idea how long have
they been streaming for I don't even
know I don't know I don't know I have no
damn idea but you know this entire time
that I've been streaming it's it's cool
just because you see you you see so much
potential in the beginning phases and
then you realize like oh I'm not even
close to where I should be I need to do
a lot more and god I do so um what I'm
probably going to do next is I'm going
to try to go south there's some good
symbol reads down here I've got to dig
past my water just to be careful once
once they clear this section out and it
kind of drains into here I'm gonna have
to what I got to do is I have to shore
up this this whole place I've got to dig
it out a bit more I've got to dig it
down so it's not on sand number one and
then I have to basically make it into a
big vat so what what I'm looking at here
is the outline of my of my basically tub
then I'm gonna have for this and so I
have to draft the outline in my head and
then they can build two over so instead
of this I'm actually gonna have it be
built from here down and then what they
could do is you can build a cross like
this and then they should be able to
reach everything that they need to build
everything else from here they if you
build ladders across like this it's
better than building tiles and then
trying to do it because water can pass
through ladders if you built a tile over
that water will be gone and it's also
ladders in general better for building
like when you're digging out huge chunks
of the map because it just makes it
easier for yourself and everything else
say you're trying to do so once they get
whatever the hell they're doing which I
don't exactly know what they're doing
we've got plenty of food now we've got a
lot of food we've got tons and tons of
food so we're doing good on that front
just don't know why they're taking so
long to do this [ __ ] so in the next
duplicate now I'm gonna get another one
I'm actually gonna speed it up to max
speed just because I want to hurry this
along everyone spam research I don't
need to research what am I gonna
research nothing I'm gonna research your
mom I've got I've got some all the
research that I basically need for right
now I've got a good oxygen generation I
am I've got a decent algae store I'll
get more algae as I go further into the
slime area and
if I need more algae I can go into I can
go into the purple areas the purple
areas have enormous stores of algae like
this is all just a huge dense pieces of
algae there's tons of it available in
addition to coal even algae in here and
also the percolators they've massively
upgraded the percolators the percolators
are completely overpowered now you can
make way more than you would ever need
to in a percolator if you don't know
what I'm talking about in the refinement
section you know the bio distiller sorry
percolation research it's a bio
distiller and then it's just ludicrous
just how much you could do with that
because it makes it takes like three
grams of slime and it turns it into a
hundred grams algae and 100 grams of
contaminated water now it's way way more
than you'd ever need and then puffs
sorbet but basically all you would never
need to be able to make what you need to
make unrefrigerated okay we're fine so
we got that makes sense so I'm gonna get
that I have not played breath of the
wild yet I haven't had a chance I don't
have a switch I didn't order a switch so
I'm sort of like not really in it you
know in a rush to do so but I don't have
a switch so it's um it's just
interesting because it looks like like
by all accounts everyone seems to think
that it's just a really really cool game
and I'm super excited about that and I
really like the fact that that is what
it is but at the same time it's uh I
personally don't have one and I'm not in
a rush to play it like I I'm a fan of
Zelda but I I haven't played every Zelda
known to man do not trap yourself over
there okay good
yeah so it's just one of those things
that I will get to eventually but I just
you know I don't I don't know if I'm
gonna do that
let's see oh you can play it on the Wii
U I don't know if I'd want to do that
though you know whenever I like I I know
it's a really shitty and uppity thing
for me to say but oh sorry my back hurts
really badly I know it's an uppity thing
for me to say but even so it's just like
oh god damn why can't you build I guess
that's fine I've got one guy that can't
build I've got one guy that can dig that
would be fun he's got divers lungs he's
a quick learner which is awesome
divers lungs is like the best thing
because that means they they don't
breathe as much air like your whole
place is gonna be better in his stinky
I love stinky he's cool or I could get
fast and digging and then not been able
to build does his fart but he's got
divers lungs a quick learner
I'm gonna go for stinky I love stinky
he's so good
I love stinky okay welcome to the family
stinky all right good for you
I should have gotten the other one I
know it's it's it's really limiting to
have someone that can't do something
especially when it comes to building and
digging but I guess it's better to not
be able to dig than it is to not be able
to build wait turn that around I have no
idea I don't know what I'm talking about
I have got no idea okay so they're
slowly getting in this one and they're
slowly gonna do this as soon as they're
done building digging through this area
here because I just want I kind of just
want this set up then I'll be able to
dig straight down because I just don't
want to dig down and then this water is
gonna get in the way of that water and
then this water is gonna go AWOL all
that [ __ ] I just got to protect my water
for right now do I like minecraft I I
guess you could still say that I do I do
I mean I haven't played it in a while
last time I played it was for drunk
minecraft I have had the same weird
ambition to come back to Minecraft
because when I was back home
over the holidays I I i loaded up
minecraft for the first time in probably
years I loaded up minecraft and I got
like really oddly emotional about it
aye-aye-aye
the music hit me and the music hit me in
a way that I hadn't
hadn't heard the music well Oh Ellie
what are you doing
Ellie can you not move away
what well that doesn't make any sense
why can't Ellie move there we go geez
don't do that Ellie you dummy anyways
the music hit me and it moved me like it
had really really moved me I I
thoroughly thoroughly thoroughly enjoyed
that music and that's one of my favorite
things that's always been about
minecraft is the music the simplicity of
it the simplicity of the music and the
experience in death just kind of like
being there in this world this empty
world where you're alone and you're the
only creator I don't know it's just like
and that always spoke to me and so I've
had this weird desire to go back into
Minecraft and to see it again anew and
and do like a small series or a
livestream of just minecraft no mods no
nothing no extras just seeing what
they've made the game to be for the sake
of the game itself and nothing more
and I've had that desire for a while to
do that I just don't know the right
medium to do it but in a way I'm kind of
doing that right now it's playing like a
gaming that's kind of like Minecraft
Ellie why do you keep getting stranded
yeah you fall no Ellie are you kidding
me Ellie what are you - Ellie you dummy
why are you up there you can't dig she's
the only one that can't dig your way out
and she's gone man
you are some kind of stupid Ellie
fall there you'll fall all the way down
oh good for you you fell yeah dummy
anyway sorry I know oh you guys are so
sweet you guys are so sweet I know I
know you guys would watch but sometimes
you know doing doing videos on YouTube
isn't just about you know what I want
and don't don't take that specifically I
always do videos that I want to do or I
try to anyway
III don't often do things you know just
for the sake of doing emerges or the
sake of you know a cool new game or
something like that but at the same time
that's like it's a very it's a very
selfish reason to play a game and I
always like to think of the channel as a
whole whenever I'm doing something like
that
not that it's entirely selfish and I
know a lot of people would like that but
you guys are sweet thank you Ellie needs
him that bed to delegate damaged no
Ellie's good she's good she's alright
Ellie's dumb but Marc is epic thanks for
that should play rust
um the thing about rust is we tried Bob
and I tried to get back into rust but
what we found was that uh it it just
wasn't it wasn't very fun you know we
were playing it again and those big open
world survival games like I was playing
Ark recently wellas away and that game
was fun because it was a lot to it but
at the same time it was I don't know it
was just it was burdensome
it's a burdensome game to get into it's
one of those games that's hard to get
started in and I know that you guys
would be awesome you guys would help me
out with that and I appreciate that all
the time you guys are lovely like that
but you know at the same time it is
still kind of a burden to get into end
and that detracts from the fun of it
like I'm not saying it's the way I gotta
remember to make him not an artist
no offense stinky but I have a funny
feeling that your art would be terrible
and so it's just it's one of the and I
like I like games that take a while to
get into like don't get me wrong I
played World of Warcraft for years and
there's no other game that's harder to
get into than World of Warcraft but I
also don't like it's like it's set up to
be antagonistic towards new players
almost it's like built to keep people
down and I played this other game that
was a lot likely that was I was debating
putting this out why Ellie is that Ellie
[Music]
Wade oh my god you are kidding me
red alert frickin get Wade out of there
oh my god Wade's not gonna make it
that is just oh no oh no no no no no no
no no no cancel that cancel what are you
doing red alert on Wade oh boy oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait move move Wade what
are you doing Wade move wait what are
you doing wait why are you not getting
air get frickin air oh wait are you
breathing okay Wade's breathing good god
people are just scaring the [ __ ] out of
me okay
well then all right
everybody please yellow wait for me tell
them that uh everybody please tweet it
Wade remember to breathe tell them just
tweeted them to breathe in in mass
everybody if you've got a Twitter
account tweet at Lord minion 777
remember to breathe it's something that
you guys have said to me many many times
over and over and over again so why
don't you tell him in my subnautica
series I often forget how to breathe but
if you guys could just pass on the word
for him to breathe I would greatly
appreciate that that would be I'd be
wonderful thank you thank you for doing
that you know if you could just pass
that message along to good old way Deepu
that would be great not in a mean way
not in a mean way it's nothing mean
about it we're not trying to be mean
here just trying to a friendly a
friendly reminder to good old Wade that
he needs to UM yep yeah yeah that's just
all I'd like to say about that okay all
right what am I doing here I'm trying to
get down to those Reed's we're doing
great on food temperatures relatively
good man this shot of adrenaline really
wore me out
good god Oh for a friendly reminder to
everyone who's hasn't been here since
the beginning I'm sick I have the flu
I'm on the tail end of it so I'm on the
up end of it but it's this big body ache
like just headache weakness flu I've got
no strength in me so getting better
about that but I just need to remember
what the hell I was trying to do here
because honestly I do not remember and I
don't think they can get down to that
song I need to build a new ones there
I'm just gonna go straight down from
here because it seems like I'm going to
have some trouble doing this whole thing
so what I need is there's gonna be some
contaminated oxygen coming through there
that I don't want so I'm gonna have to
make a two-stage vertical airlock which
is something I've never really made
before and then I'm gonna have to make
basically two different I'm gonna make
two different air deodorizers right here
and right here
yeah those works yeah
can you get out are you okay
all right I will get well soon thanks so
much for that
I will oh hi hello everybody just
walking in their thoughts on the
Nintendo switch it's cool I like the
concept I don't know if it's gonna be as
revolutionary as the Wii was but just
having the ability to take take real
Nintendo games everywhere that's that is
a really good concept that is something
that is really interesting that I'm
personally very interested in cuz
mobility is like the future obviously
mobile is everything Mobile is
everywhere mobile is exactly what you
know everything is being built for so it
makes sense in terms of making gaming
accessible wherever you want to go
because that's what people are more and
more expected of being able to do when
they are able to take their phone
everywhere and I like I like the I like
the things again you know a lot of
reliance on motion controls which take
it or leave it
it is what it is you know Nintendo likes
it so they're gonna do whatever they
like to do but you know still it's
interesting I'd have to see what other
games take full advantage of the mobile
ability of it and the ability to take it
out and also play multiplayer games with
people is another very interesting thing
it's it's very very good very good use
of the technology but you know I just
got to see it I haven't been able to
have one for myself I've played on it
just haven't been able to do it so I
have to see how that goes
slime rancher oh man I haven't have to
please slime rancher in a long time
I really haven't I want to like in a
weird way like I want to just to see
what kind of updates have been done with
the game but I don't know I just don't
know about that
I you know yeah I don't know III unless
there's been drastic improvements to the
game and there's actually like a
storyline like I don't know it's cute
like the game is cutesy and I think
that's all I was like really cool
sometimes but at the same time you know
kind of want a bit more substance out of
it I like this the [ __ ] and sculpture by
the by the outhouse over here fist fight
my flu fist my flu and it's weird I
don't think I can do that I don't think
I can Bioshock I have played Bioshock
before and I have played it for maybe
one or two of you guys a long time ago
when I did my first charity livestream I
played Bioshock and it's just a pain
because like the like the game's hard
Bioshock is hard even on like Normal
difficulty the game is supposed to be
very difficult but as I got more tired
because I've never really done a 24 hour
livestream and I didn't know I was
getting into I didn't pace myself in
terms of like energy into like
commentary and one man so towards the
end of it I just started getting really
mad and really tired because it was just
so hard to keep up the energy do the
like keep up the energy do commentary
come up with things to say and then play
a game while I wasn't used to it was
like the first charity livestream it was
only like four or five months into me
doing YouTube at all so doing that was
just oh it was that was a thing I'm
gonna get meat meeps coming in here
meeps the face only a 12-ton DNA
replicator could love oh yeah so it was
it was very it was very difficult for me
I'm gonna need to get more oxygen
generation pretty much immediately now
so what I'm gonna do exactly that damn
you I don't want to build there oh I
guess this this water is all gone by now
yeah this waters gone this water is
pretty much in there so I can build that
there you know where do you come from
and then build up there so we're gonna
build more terrariums to Rios and then
yeah that'll work cuz then I can double
up on the plants getting then once I get
more bristle blossoms I'll be able to do
that a little better
I see house chica chica is wonderful
she's in the rudder room it was it was
like exploit she's always exploding
whenever I pick her up from the the dog
hotel that I had put her in and she's
used to sweetest sweetest pup to ever
bump in the entire world she's the
cutest little bump loved her to death
love everything about her god she's so
cute what did I ever do to deserve a dog
like that I have no idea lucky but uh so
yeah we have that she's doing super well
we can't complain at all she is awesome
[Music]
and yeah it's good
I sound like Bob Ross I don't know
I'm just I'm just low-energy right now
don't mind me as I just whisper my way
through the next few things SCP
containment breach I do intend to play a
Seabee containment breach again I really
do and I'm not I'm not joking about that
I know I said that a while ago but I
really mean that I want to play it again
like there's been updates to the game
it's it's uh it's it's um it's I I
really hope they sell it for money
because god they deserve some money out
of that but you know it's still free as
far as I know and there's been some
updates to it so I got to play it again
I think I know those this is thing I
tried to play it for some reason I
couldn't get it to play with good frame
rates for some reason I don't know why
but I couldn't get it to play properly
so I have to try that again at some
point because I know it's still good so
I just got to do it but I just don't
know what I'm gonna be able to do that
so ooh look at this big open area that's
not what I was hoping for
okay yeah cuz I wanted this as opposed
to that okay what am i doing I have no
idea why is it still there get rid of
that uh you should sleep I'll sleep
later it's it's still early for me like
I don't need to sleep yet I I got plenty
of sleep last night and I'll get plenty
of sleep tonight and then um then later
tonight I'm going to do videos for
tomorrow I've got a special video
special video in store that I think you
guys are gonna like has to do with the
trampoline place that we want to yeah
and then some other stuff in store and
then I don't know what I'm gonna play
first if I'm a place of not occur if I'm
gonna play Finding Bigfoot like both are
good options I'm just a simple fiber I
need those all right so I'm almost down
there I'm just really hoping that there
isn't gonna be a geyser down here too
cuz that is like having geysers this
close just oh but it seems like they
rolled out an update an update to the
the update patch this patch is not final
yet they did a preview buildin I don't
want to be very clear that this is a
development build this isn't like a
public release alpha yet so they're
still testing these thermal features so
I think they updated it to have more
thimble reads around in more puffs
actually which is really nice of them
now good for them so I'm gonna do that
why is there I'm not doing anything why
isn't knowing down here just dig damn it
just dig you dingus you didn't damn
dinguses they're just a bunch of lazy
[ __ ] is what they are it is eaten
the food that I grew for them and then
doing a whole lot of nothing fine
whatever no really
oxygen is having trouble getting over
there but I think it's okay yeah that's
fine yeah it's nothing to worry about
it's how you guys doing any questions
for me let's see play this Sims
I I kind of want to do a uh like an
actual serious playthrough The Sims you
know a lot of what I found what I found
recently is uh I spent like I talked
about this a little before below I found
with like subnautica and what that's
what that stuff is I would have a bad
habit of playing a game for the sake of
playing the game or no I would play a
game for the sake of the joke of the
game and not for what the game actually
has to offer and I and I did that you
know with you know with like the Sims I
would play it to play a joke I would
play it to do a silly thing and that's
not always a bad thing like I love doing
that and I'm not gonna stop doing that
but with like The Sims like I can set up
a jokey situation like I can make a
million marks a million different
versions of mark like every version of
mark that I have and then you know I can
I can utilize that as a funny thing why
is that why is that getting damaged no
idea can we put a rush on this [ __ ] can
you just finish this please so like I do
that for the sake of doing it instead of
you know actually doing it for the sake
of the game which is sometimes even more
fun and something that I can enjoy a lot
more why is this getting damaged is it
because it's structurally unstable there
maybe because that shouldn't be getting
damaged why would that be getting
damaged why is that getting damaged
that doesn't make any sense Oh oh my god
cuz the oxygen pressure is too high
why is the oxygen pressure too high okay
so what I need to do is whoa what is
that
where's that oxygen coming from did I
cut through
I must have let's open this up open this
because that's what it's causing damage
here is there's just a lot of oxygen
being tossed around like a rag doll here
I don't know why you open that up okay
goodbye holy [ __ ] yeah I don't know what
that was happening anyway can we cut
these open all right yeah what was I
talking about I have no oh market could
never place your ethnicity I am a half
Korean half German they're my ethnicity
has been placed let's see your walls are
damaged I know they're damaged I can see
that I'm talking about how they're
damaged right now I think also maybe
because these are not allowing gas to
permeate I didn't make those permeable
tiles
do you like Fran bow yeah I really like
Fran bow I think Fran bow was a good
game Bob what are you doing still up go
to bed Catherine why are you sleeping
down there
bed beyond reach what you can't talk it
about why do they keep having so much
trouble getting through here yeah yeah
yes I know I am I'm Korean yes that
often comes at a surprise to some people
yes I'm Korean
if you guys have seen the video that I
did with my mother you would know that
I'm extremely Korean well not extremely
I guess exactly 50% curry
Oh No what's that sound
please tell me that wasn't the sound of
a geyser no I hear something maybe it's
just these tiles okay I'm hoping that
solved the problem right No
whoa okay anyway um would I recommend
this game absolutely
this game is lovely it costs 20 bucks
right now so it's a bit pricey
especially for an alpha but that's only
considering what alphas normally give
you this game god this game it has so
much in here you I've spent over a
hundred hours playing this game oh [ __ ]
they're all idle oopsies I've spent over
a hundred hours playing this game just
because there's so much to do always
there's always stuff to do it is super
fun it is just like I I can't get enough
of it I can't stop solving the problems
that are presented in front of me I
can't stop trying to figure a way around
what I'm doing here like I just I can't
stop it's so fun all the time like all
the time it's fun I've never not had fun
with it I've gotten frustrated with it
at times but fun non-stop why is that
guy eating my [ __ ] don't eat my blossom
don't eat it yeah you better run
get ready baby you're about to get a
whole lot of about to get a whole face
full of stinky here no up stinky okay
not going there alright then
where did this come from well you're
saying there yeah
do I like kpop um actually no I I've
never really tried to go so I can't say
whether I'd like it or not whoa he's
about to get attacked meep meep can't
fight meat move your ass you stupid
person forgiveness Oh God kill it we
don't forgive we don't forget all right
I guess since their Idol I'm gonna
research them that base stuff in the way
I can heal people up quicker than that
play a little big planet but do you guys
want a little big planet playthrough I
mean I I like little big planet I've
never really had much of an opportunity
to play it but I don't know do you guys
like it would you guys want that
because it's something I could
definitely do I would do it I would do
it multiplayer I wouldn't want to just
do it by myself one thing this
single-player campaign is interesting
enough to be able to do that
this guy's got some good all over
aspects a little bit of a little bit of
everything my favorite thing but can't
cook which is fine yeah I think I think
if I make a learning that's always good
I always like learning because over time
that means this guy is gonna have way
more way more Skills than say someone
who doesn't have a lot of learning not
an incredible amount but you know that's
gonna gonna have like double what this
guy does uh the only problem is he's
destructive well it's my objective in
this particular game to not make them I
really don't want people to get stressed
is what I want I want everyone to be
able to be happy and unstressed so I'm
not going the vomiting route so I'm
hoping that everyone's okay
so he's gonna be one of two destructive
people in this whole game will I ever
get a tattoo I don't think so
I've said before the only tattoo I'd
ever did is the one that my dad had
which is was this big American flag and
Eagle and like I think the words honor
duty courage something like that and I
would get that because it was meaningful
but I still don't think that I'm going
to get one because I don't know I just I
don't have an ambition to get I don't
have an ambition to get a tattoo I've
never felt this driving driving need to
get a tattoo like some people they're
like I have to do this I have to do this
because it's me it's Who I am and I
totally respect that but for me
personally like I've never felt that
drive I've never really felt the
strong desire to do that I've always
felt like I'm comfortable with just no
marks on my skin and whatnot pun
intended or not I'm not entirely sure at
this point because I know some people
are injured okay so I've gotten a lot of
liquid but I'm I'm a so the interesting
thing is I have to start thinking about
water now it may seem like I have a lot
of water and I do have a lot of water
I've got tons of water and I'm only
using water to really you make food and
water my algae and that's fine but it's
at this point that I really really
really have to start thinking about
water and how I'm going to get water
what I'm going to do when I get water
and that's where the geyser comes in
because that'll create unlimited water
but at the same time I don't have the
option for unlimited water right now
so what I got to do is I got to figure
out a way to get things moving and I
think a lot of that's gonna come from
and be going down into these slime zones
but the only problem is these are very
narrow slime zones it's like this in
this and then this and this the only big
slime zone is actually up here but I
don't know if I want to do all that up
there because then waters just gonna
fall on top of my head and it's gonna be
hard to get that all situated but there
is a narrow channel there that I could
carve up it's just really narrow but I
guess either one's good so the only
reason I'm going down here now is to get
this stuff because it's easily
accessible so let's go ahead and God why
is it still being damaged I don't get
that that doesn't make any sense to me
I may just have to shut all this off
because there's a stupid way to go or
something like that but I have it so
might as well use it so I'm gonna go
down there I'm gonna collect this stuff
I'm gonna sweep it up I need to start
making wanna stir making storage
containers because that's one thing that
I definitely don't have
where is all my storage storage
compactors because basically it helps
with the decor to keep the the ground
swept but also it helps with literally
everything else to have have things in
an easily accessible area so that people
aren't running for miles and miles to
get resources to be able to build and I
know it's it's a waste of space to do
like this but I I really got no other
choice here so um I'm gonna double stack
them over here and that's probably where
I should have that's not correct
okay very sorry about that got
distracted for a second I'm gonna listen
yeah let's not do that there I want them
over here eventually I'm gonna have
liquid tiles here but I don't think I
need it I don't know why I needed I just
got to make sure people don't go too far
away from the outhouses see thoughts on
ASMR videos I'm not I'm not a big
proponent why did I do this I'm really
done I'm not a big proponent of ASMR not
that I'd like to think it's all [ __ ]
people definitely derive some joy out of
it and I don't know I don't care the
funny do that derive joy it's good but I
personally you know I don't get anything
out of ASMR I I've never thought about
doing a some are myself just because I
don't see the biggest purpose in doing
it I get why some people do it don't get
me wrong I get it but just me I I don't
you know I don't do a lot with with ASMR
so it's never really it's not really
something for me god damnit why is water
just constantly leaking through here
that doesn't make any sense I mean the
waters high pressure of course but maybe
because it's not double-reinforced
I've never really built a ladder right
next to it and a basin like this so it's
probably cuz it's not reinforced like
that
there's a lot of water leaking through
and I don't know why I don't want to
double reinforce it in here cuz I'm
gonna lose all that water if I do that
hmm weird tf2 man tf2 so old now not
saying and saying like that but you know
tf2 I don't know I think it's past his
heyday hype laid the crap out of us tf2
I've got I've got tons of hours logged
into tf2 I've got I've got oodles and
oodles and oodles of hours logged into
it and I love the game but you know I
just I don't know I I just I feel like
there's there's a there's more more
things to do at this point then tf2
overwatch kind of took a lot of the
thunder of tf2 and you know there's
there's more stuff to be done in tf2 and
obviously there's still updates going on
but when it comes to tf2 itself I don't
know csgo CS player I'm not really a
counter-strike player much at all I
don't know what what else I could do
with it I used to be big in this
counter-strike and I used to play it a
lot I used to love it but then it like
the competitiveness like I I'm just not
I'm just not much of a super competitive
gamer like I my blossoms are blossoming
like I'm not a terribly huge competitive
gamer so I find competitive gaming
especially online competitive gaming to
be taxing for me like I get the same
adrenaline rush that everyone else does
god dammit with you know with everything
like that but as far as like as far as
you know everything else goes like ah I
often just don't feel don't feel like
it's fun for me not that it's not fun
for everybody else but for me yeah you
know it's not as fun as it could be so I
try to find find other things to do
and you guys build these quicker I need
the thimbles Oh who's sick who's injured
now you are meep meep was getting this
[ __ ] kicked out of him all right yeah
play Minecraft I was just talking about
play Terraria I was just talking about
oh no I wasn't talking about terraria
but same concept you know terraria kind
of like this game
but this one like this one is
fundamentally different because it's
more of a calming colony simulator than
me actively doing these things so I just
set these guys two tasks and that's why
I like like that I don't know I put
personality in them and I think it
reflects something about my character
that I probably shouldn't let it get to
me but I I don't know I just I can't
help but putting put personalities into
these guys because I just I think
they're cute they they're adorable and I
love them but you know igneous rock my
igneous rock it picks the weirdest
things sometimes to make it out of and
so like I often put personality into
these guys and I think that's part of
the charm because each of these these
are the people they're like people than
me so I'm like a stinky how you doing
they're stinky are you doing so good I
mean I'm using so much water on this
these things I got a I got a good water
see that's why I got to get water now
cuz it went down it was five hundred
thousand before now it's not five
hundred thousand any more so I
definitely got to get water in there
have you guys build these yeah can you
freakin build these you're freaking
[ __ ] can you do that for me how can
you frickin do that please well or you
can go to bed thanks guys okay
good job everybody being stupid alright
yeah do you like pointless games I I do
I do like point clickers there's a
purpose forum do I miss Slender games
now that's an interesting question uh in
their heyday I guess but then you know I
look back because one slender first came
out I didn't really I wasn't really
introduced to the concept of the indie
horror game you know I really wasn't I
had no idea what that could mean so when
it came to
you know the concept of in the horror it
really it really is an alien alien thing
so I I need to make sure that I could
this all done correctly god I hate
organizing these things so it was like
so when it came down to it it was uh it
was trying to say sorry I'm thinking
about this okay so and then Industrial
gradients I don't know I also want to
make sure these aren't for liquefiable
sorry my brains still not working what
was I talking about I've totally
forgotten what I was talking about
I don't know I'm sick I got the flu for
those ears didn't know most of you
already noticed I was talking about L
he's got a minor one who's getting the
rejuvenator really
what the hell was I talking about
I don't remember I did not remember
[Music]
no idea and I've I slander games that's
right oh my god okay all right uh being
sick is no excuse for forgetting about
that Slugger games okay so I didn't know
the concept of indie horror games at the
time because what did that even mean I
was just playing horror games I barely
scratched the surface of what horror
games were so indie horror games were
kind of like that's what they're called
that I don't know anything else about it
so when I had these indie horror games I
didn't even realize that that's what the
Sunderman games were these were small
games made it very crudely with a
formula like it was inherently formulaic
not that there's anything wrong with
that but that is what it was it was
formulaic so looking back on them I
realized that there was a there was a
lot to be desired in those games um but
then came along like the bigger Slender
games like slender the arrival which had
a lot of potential and I think it fell
short of it just a little bit but even
so it was still like it was still cool
in its own way and I think that's you
know III think that that is the kind of
slender game that I I miss it's weird
considering there
very recently was a a you know
a rake game not very reasonable
obviously the things 2015 but there was
a rake game you know and the rake was
like popular before the Slenderman was
like it all rose from like this
creepypasta area era of like 2010 to
2012 and 2013 so when you think about
all that old stuff you think about like
the memories of what happened back then
and like those types of scare games and
how that that was kind of defining what
horror was and yet you know the horror
is is often ill-defined and like very
nebulous and that in is in and of itself
is pretty cool the debating putting
ceiling lamps of beer just because get
the minor efficiency boost lamb why not
[Music]
got a one I don't want to run heavy walk
through there it's gonna take so much
metal ok anyway yeah um Final Fantasy
games I I've only ever played two Final
Fantasy games to completion and that was
seven and ten and by completion I mean
100% the game which is really the only
way that I thought was to approach that
these get a small boost only 10% but
it's a small boost it gets a little more
oxygen for the water it produces water
it uses so I so I so I I haven't really
had much experience with the Final
Fantasy series I
I heard decent things about the new one
but I just haven't had I don't have the
time for that like that's so much time
it's it's an unbelievable amount of time
just to be able to play that in wow
those those propped back up nice
I forgot that those grow a lot quicker
yeah but anyway so four down here I
don't know if that's gonna be the best
bet to go down there but it is already
accessible god dammit stop doing that
why are you being such a dick bag I
don't know what to do about that I guess
I got a double wallet I don't want to do
that
because I just don't know why it's being
such a douche like why is it being a
douche it's being a douche I can't help
but it's just douche you know stop that
with your splurging water around there
okay Last Guardian um I don't think so
I uh not that it's a bad game obviously
again if we again never take it as well
I'm not gonna play the game as I think
it's bad that's a terrible way to think
about life but it's just not for me
I appreciate the art of that a game and
I appreciate the art of you know shadow
the colossus cuz like they're there
along the same vein or one's a spiritual
successor the other but I've just never
felt the strongest need to play them
because I you know this is me I'm not
I'm not the all the all fulfilling
definer what is a good game or not but
you know I just I don't know I have I
have a hard time getting getting into a
game I have a hard time I have a hard
time just you know I have a hard time
just letting myself fall into certain
games and live in that world and and
I've tried I've tried with Shadow of the
Colossus and I've tried with I've tried
with various other games like that
it is hard for me to get cuz I have to
be in the right mood I have to be in the
right mindset to be able to sit down and
do that but the tragic thing is I
haven't been able to play games on my
own for a long time I I you know I wish
I had more time to play games I really
do but I don't like I I honestly and
truly don't I
I find myself often you know having to
work more than I would you know that I
would
no just be playing games instead and and
that's not a that's not a bad thing you
know work is fine work is good and this
is still breaking I have no idea why
that is breaking like that that that
makes very little sense to me I've never
seen anything like that and that's
that's bad cuz that's threatening my
water supply because without that I got
no water or my water is just gonna be
spilling out all over the entire place
which is also not good so yeah it's like
I I find myself working a lot more than
you know more than I have been in the
past and and so uh that's not a bad
thing but you know I don't often have
time for games like I used to why is
that breaking why doesn't make any sense
it shouldn't be able to break through
two tiles like that that's just like
improbable
oh whatever
hopefully that holds anyway yeah more
Finding Bigfoot hmm yeah I appreciate
the the game suggestions but like I said
before compiling a list as opposed to
just shouting it into the void in the
comments section not that I don't
appreciate you guys talking to me but it
will get lost and it will get forgotten
and I know it's tempting because the
guys are talking to me right now but you
could be talking to me about more
important meaningful topics than that
then just game suggestions because to be
honest I don't have that much time so um
if you got more things two more things
you task me go for it I am all ears I am
100% here right now
no puffs stop sucking it in
press B to blow I don't think B does
blow in this game I'm pretty sure B is
the opposite of blow in this game in
fact I'm pretty sure if anything were to
blow in this game it would be very bad
and everyone would die what is one thing
I hate clay developers if you guys can
tell every for you guys watching can
tell the clay developers can you tell it
to stop defaulting to the most rare
material whenever I want to build
something I don't want to build things
out of obsidian when I have no obsidian
I want to build things out of sandstone
because that's what I have an assload of
so don't do that
that's no good please I'm you making me
mad and I go punch face that's what I do
I go punch you face if you do that I
punch you face sound good okay good all
right cool now that we're on the same
page
so what I need to do is I need to make a
percolator and then I didn't make a
filtration system so that's exactly what
I'm going to do I'm gonna do exactly
that I'm gonna I'm a man of my word I'm
gonna do that alright so what I got to
do is I got to dig out so we've got a
dig dig dig dig dig there's a lot of
algae here there's a lot of good slime
here we're not gonna dig this out
because that would be detrimental to
what I'm trying to do because I need to
keep that alive these are these are
things that are actually used in the new
tile called
oh and that's an advanced food I think
yeah aquatic farm tile if you want to be
able to farm these Reed's you have to
farm them in aquatic farm tiles and
that's cool but I don't have time to do
that because I'm worried about my water
situation I need a lot more water so I'm
going to work on that as opposed to
working on that first so I need to dig
this out when that when they're crawling
on a ladder this is why it's good for
digging out they can they can walk they
can reach for up and three downs so when
you're building these ladders and you're
trying to clear them out you can
actually you can actually be real
efficient about this
and probably gonna lose that puffed so
you can technically do it like this and
then you would be able to do all of this
from that ladder and if this was farther
out it could do two more up just like
that
tada and the more you know okay so once
I'm over here I can actually get all
this contaminated water into a single
place and then I can make a percolator
over it and I can just show you guys
just how percolated this [ __ ] gonna get
and it gonna get a real perk real
percolated who that guy is pretty good
but too bad I don't have space for you
guys pretty good too oh no he's level
zero lump I've never seen a lump I've
never seen a lump in my life huh he's
got a lot of boosts tuned
well I don't have room we got any people
that's enough for now eventually I'll
move up to ten but I don't want that I
don't want that for know oh [ __ ] I
forgot no I forgot to dig these up after
these I've got more than enough food
I've got 127 121,000 kilocalories a
little puffed okay
yeah so anyway anyway I got more more
suggestions more comments I'm gonna make
a save I haven't saved in a while it
saves automatically but you might as
well good I think I gotta like he's over
there before they where they replanted
eventually I'm gonna just trade them all
out with blossom seeds but I'm just
gonna wait one more go of it before I do
that I've got a lot of blossom so you
tell me all right got those okay so
they're digging out there and that Reed
is in a chilly environment which is bad
that's okay because I think industrial
ingredient I've got seven thimble fibre
which means that that's enough to make
one suit you need five thimble fiber
pursuit for each thing and if you want
to deck out your whole guys you got to
get them suits in one flavor or another
I don't know I've done I've never done
that before I just know what it is to do
it's your most loved game I have no idea
right now is this one but I don't know
people ask me that all the time most
loved is different than favorite which I
appreciate the differentiation but you
know it's just hard to say it's not just
today why am I so quiet I'm sick I keep
forgetting them new people come in all
the time so I have the flu I'm very sick
and I'm just doing a very chilled stream
because I get to talk to you guys and I
don't know get to enjoy this just kind
of like relax which is something that I
haven't been able to do a lot I don't
know being sick
it sucks cuz all you can do is just
relax because that's all you're
prescribed to do by your doctor but it's
still that's still nice it's nice to be
here and doing this chillers why this
chili doesn't seem like a bit chilly
anyway
you loves my frozen two trailer that's
awesome
bring back reading your comments I had I
had plans for bringing back and reading
your comments I'd away though I was
gonna do it but then as is typical with
me I change what I want to do a lot as I
find new things I change what I want to
do is so I had I had a plan for I had a
plan for reading your comments and then
I shifted things around not that I'm not
going to do it but I'll have to rethink
how I would want to do it if I were to
do that again sorry I'm just feeling ill
right now you should talk about
something sad why would I do that why
would that be something I should do I
appreciate the offer but I think oh
nothing I'm fine on my own
let's watch dogs - I don't think so I
tried to play watchdogs one on my own
and it wasn't it just wasn't my type of
game I wasn't I wasn't down to clown
with it I've got so much food Jesus that
is so much food the hell am I gonna do
with all that food that's too much food
there's so much food there's so much
food seasons okay well I've got a lot of
food so that's nice I'm gonna worry
about it at least it's refrigerators
get run but and then it's a lot of food
okay so as soon as they get this under
way here I'm going to build the
percolators which are gonna need their
own power supply because I don't think
I'm gonna be able to send a wire all the
way down there that's gonna be so much I
really like honestly I have to think
about my metal consumption because each
of these wires the heavy want which I
have to make it out of they take a
hundred metal and you know you wouldn't
think that would be a lot when they used
to be just twenty-five but when you got
to run a wire all the way down there
that's a lot of things to consider when
you got a problem like that so what I
could probably do I can run double duty
here because there's water here I can
have I can have power plants I can have
coal generators over here because I
think I've got I've got decent of
medical not a lot that's not gonna last
me a long time but I can put one coal
generator in here
start digging out this stuff and then
heating up this environment here it's
not gonna do a lot of melting and
frankly it's around a lot of polluted
stuff and it's right by a wheeze wort so
that's not gonna do me a whole lot of
good but what that can do is it can give
me an independent power supply that's
gonna be able to melt this and provide
power for the percolators to be able to
get me more polluted water and more
algae so it's kind of two-for-one
ideally you know what I mean
so for these I'm going to need normal
tile right up until I'm gonna need mesh
tile you can see the polluted water
actually there's polluted ice here and
then there's good ice there's clean ice
and then there's polluted ice so
polluted ice is gonna make obviously
polluted water and that's no good but I
didn't research combustion of
this is what I get for not letting him
do research here so I didn't I'm dumb
and I didn't prepare before I was ready
but uh but it's good no shower why do
they need a shower they don't need a
shower they're fine they're fine being
dirty and grimy why would I I would I
get him a shower that's just a waste of
my water oh yeah you guys like only to
my own E as oxygen not included as it's
cold now yeah I really love it god I
love this game so much I don't even know
why I don't even know it's simplistic
and you know kind of plays itself but
you just have to think about it and plan
very very very carefully most of us on
and I think that's just it scratches an
itch it scratches a certain niche and I
cannot help them be all about that yeah
can't help it it's super good hygiene is
key I don't think so I'm pretty sure
they can be the dirtiest thank-yous this
side of the West Pecos and I don't think
it's gonna matter for anybody here I've
gotta I've got it well handled they can
be the dirtiest the dirtiest around and
I don't think they're gonna complain
known about not having a shower yeah
presents prevents diseases by improving
hygiene you know what I found it doesn't
matter if they're sick really doesn't
doesn't have any effect one way or
another if they're sick or not so I'm
just gonna let them be sick I'm gonna
just because I can I'm gonna get them
something to do over there boink
okay just because like what else you
know else can I do while they're
researching oh did you start a new game
yes I did because this is a new patch
this is an update where there is much
more in the way of thermal thermal
concerns temperature is a big thing this
this is cold this is called wheeze wart
and a wheeze wart creates cold air by
filtering there's like a perpetual
source of cold you can't you can make
you can make cooling fans and whatnot
but to get a perpetual source of cold
like this you have to you have to plant
these things where you need them but
they need to be planted in a relatively
cold environment as well so yeah it's
just cool there's a lot of new things
about it and I'm really glad that I
haven't encountered a geyser yet because
every time I've encountered two guys are
on my own I died in horrible horrible
ways everyone I've known and loved has
died and that's no good according to my
main hero Sonic the Hedgehog that's no
good how can you play this game I
believe the Alpha is available on Steam
I'm not out of percent sure I believe so
it might be I don't know if that's a
hundred percent but it could be no
Harold what are you doing Harold are you
an artist
Harold ask yourself are you good at art
not as good as Wade
unfortunately sorry no he's leaving
disgruntled too bad about you I need to
get water quick because I'm not doing
this fast enough can you uh can you stop
being such an [ __ ] and do something
good with your life okay there we go so
now I've made combustion so I'm gonna
put this on hold for now
Wade's gonna continue with his painting
I'm gonna make this power because I
needed coal generator yes please and
then we're gonna need just a oodles of
batteries so I'm gonna make obviously
there's gonna be batteries on this level
okay I think that's gonna be good
actually I'm gonna use this as a
platform and also frickin Gossman is
gonna get herself killed like an idiot
and then I'm gonna use more mesh tiles I
think I'm just gonna make a row of
batteries but I couldn't make room for
another cold generator eventually if I
do I'll just make it to the left of that
I'm just gonna make more batteries
batteries batteries batteries batteries
batteries okay and then dig this out
make all of this top priority go for it
so what I'm doing here is I'm creating
power so that I can make both the pumps
needed to filter this water and then you
know I
I'll have I'm also just just as backup
because I don't know if it's gonna need
to be enough power for all that I'm
gonna have everything that I'm going to
need to both run the percolators and run
the other things that I need okay there
we go
so that should be all good there so when
those are built that's good get those
done get done quick
please make this not ask top priority
but top priority make this top priority
okay so once they're done with that I
got to build the percolators which means
that I got to build stuff down here so I
just need gas permeable
I don't need mesh tiles I just need a
gas permeable
what does that sound was anything I'll
love you too can you overload it yes you
can you can indeed overload it
you can overload pretty much anything in
this game now because if you look on
these batteries they have an overheat
temperature and then they have a
meltdown temperature and even the wires
that's you can overload the wires they
have a max wattage that they can safely
is sustained and they can explode if you
don't do it well enough so that's bad in
case you didn't know that's bad
so don't overload anything and I'm gonna
put this set of six so it's constantly
gonna have coal in it I don't have a lot
of coal but I've got enough to get
started on I'm so light okay nevermind
yeah yeah blow it all up mark I don't
know those are from the days of
Minecraft from way back when I don't
know if I should blow it all up
yes I'll be playing on the last two oh
yeah absolutely
door lock I probably could put an
airlock here probably it would be smart
to separate these environments just a
smidge I'm gonna do that I'm gonna make
this a top priority I said a top
priority there we go okay so those are
getting powered by the coal generator
that's creating heat it's not creating a
lot of heat but it is or it is creating
a lot of heat but you you won't see a
drastic change until right about there
okay so now it's creating a lot of heat
so this works doubly good because the
coal generator creates so much heat that
it creates so much heat that it can
literally melt itself down if it's not
in an environment that's going to cool
it so this will only work for a time and
it'll only work for a time
that it's able to like stay under the
right temperature and it'll heat itself
up if it gets over 275 it will start
taking damage so having it in this in
this place next to granite and stuff and
melt the bulls that are all like
negative 37 that's the only thing that's
gonna make sure that it stays cool
enough to operate see it cools down
really quickly when it's off I should
yeah that's fine okay there we go
all right so they got that about
underway I've got my manual generators
over there to keep it powered okay so
then they're gonna work on this and I
should be able to get rid of this okay
right so they got that the batteries are
charging up that's good to go good good
good
okay so this is where things get
complicated and is where everything can
go wrong usually after I after I get out
of the initial base phase this is indeed
where everything can go horrifically
wrong and it usually does so let's just
hope it doesn't this time that'd be nice
than be a welcome change can I need
water fast I need water very soon I need
water eventually what I also I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna plan for this thing to
get bigger and the only way to do that
is to do this
[Music]
Miep you stupid idiot
let me just load up my load that I just
loaded
I just saved that if meep is not being
an idiot and I know what he did he
deleted the ladder while he was on it
and then cornered himself meep is such
an idiot
if this isn't before he got down there
then there's no way I can save him
because I'm not gonna go back all the
way to the beginning of this cycle come
on load me pin Gossman are being idiots
you being stupid idiots just are you
kidding me oh my god why why why you
guys are so dumb you guys are so dumb
how can don't go over there guys alright
so at least they're not dying over there
you stupid sacks of crap and again why
did it build that out of obsidian I just
don't get that okay we got him saved him
he's a really stupid piece of [ __ ] but
we saved him
alright build this please okay alright
then
okay
anyway neaps back meeps not dead
everybody can rejoice meep is okay did I
even I didn't do the research for the
bio distiller alright well that's a
that's a bunch of fun that's a crunch a
bunch a bunch of fun alright so now that
I got the power charging and the heat
being produced so as you can see the
coal generator is actually staying
relatively cool that's not ideal because
hopefully it would have heated up the
entire environment what it's not doing
that so I need a lot more not more heat
than that to be able to melt this but at
least it's doing the purpose that I set
it out to do which is to create power
that's really the only reason why I
wanted that so that's creating power and
it's it's doing something there's a lot
of material around it like ice around it
that is absorbing heat from it and
that's probably being warmed oh yeah I
think that I just went up a tick you can
see the snow is increasing temperature
just a little bit at a time as the coal
generator is dropping in temperature but
that's because it's still producing heat
technically speaking so that's fine in
that regard so what we need to do is I
eventually need to make a pump at the
bottom of this giant tunnel here and so
this pump is going to require a liquid
pipe that's going to run up a ladder
that's going to go straight out this way
so the pump is going to need to go from
here and then and then I can have I can
have myself a filtration system which I
don't have
I need the research for it obviously
water beer farm but it's going to have
that so the power
then can be sent all the way down here
and this is rules of frickin lon metal
that I'm gonna use true through all my
metal just to make that wire down there
and then eventually in there
so yeah resource management is actually
a lot harder than it once was
so yeah it's getting it's getting rough
all my batteries are full though so
that's nice so it looks like that the
water is melted with the snow melt is
the ice melt this is getting hot why is
that getting so hot it was getting
cooler well uh no you'd better stop now
come on now
keep it together don't be like that
don't get too hot no I'm like that
disabled no no no no no no no no that's
right you better not okay you stay idle
you just cool down there see how quickly
it cools though as soon as it touches as
soon as it gets topped all right you
know I got food waiting anyway sorry
you're distracted again who are my
favorite guitars um I actually don't
really have many guitarists that I would
say I look up to III don't I don't
approach things like that in the same
way that um I don't really have a
favorite band
there's guitarists that I would listen
to you and I like to listen to but as
far as far as like idols i I don't often
have what I would call idols you know
what I mean I don't know that sounds
conceited for me to say I think but it's
true like I really don't I don't have I
don't have those people that I I want to
emulate you know what I mean and I think
that that both benefits me you know it
also hinders me because inspiration is
necessary for almost anything but you
know I don't know I like my approach my
approach is good
oh no I'm not gonna have enough metal I
have not enough metal I am just a big
old bag of dick and I so we got a what
we got to do being the big old bag of
dick that we are is we gotta dig out
this puddle here
okay there we go shoo boo okay hopefully
that'll work
I'll give me some more metal god that's
it's just like that's just the way it is
let you run out of metal so quickly like
all these things need metal metal metal
metal metal metal all this metal that I
just don't have and I wish I don't think
it does this but when you have it
requiring one thing like it won't just
default to another thing stop yelling at
me
no I don't think so new headphones no I
I just had to grab some of my other
headphones i Catherine's bar and my
headphones at the moment oh speaking of
head my head is killing me do the
research please I need it badly
Gossman is relaxing she's the one that
needs to do the research
damn you when did you feel that YouTube
was your job I don't know I don't know
but I know when I felt it was my job it
wasn't till I probably probably want to
reach the decision that I had to drop
out of college that was probably when it
became my job
because that's what I had to dedicate my
time to it was a thing a necessity you
know so that's what I did
am I tired
oh no I'm sick I'm not actually all that
tired I just I feel sick I'm probably
I'm not gonna go much longer just
because I don't think I can go much
longer I just feel I just feel all kinds
of right now so I think I probably
probably back it up in a bit but we made
a good progress here
yeah go about yeah clay messaged me on
Twitter I just I yeah I'll probably go
for about 50 more minutes I'll just get
to seven and that'll be it for me damn
it these asses won't leave me alone
no no idea
am i okay no I have the flu I mentioned
that before you may have not been here
when I first mentioned at the first in
15 billion times the people who have
been here sorry I got to repeat myself
it's not a bad thing it's just there's
always more people coming so yeah I have
to actually eventually I'm gonna get two
more beds in here because I want ten
people in here just to get more work
done I don't need to I don't even get
that many there what am i doing
massage tables stuff streaming while I'm
busy too bad I am the stream that the
most inconvenient times always I'll
never stream at a good time for anybody
[Music]
these acronyms for games that I just
don't know anymore I don't know what
Geor is I won't do a let's play of
Andromeda but never play it on my own
favorite place to go in LA um I really
like and this is me being the nerd that
I am I really like improv theaters III
go to UCB Franklin for shows sometimes
I've just gone down to that Santa Monica
won that epic Lloyd and epic Lloyd and a
few other people founded Westside comedy
theater is that the name of it I can't
remember but I love improv shows because
one it's cheap show you know yeah it's
usually like five to ten bucks maybe
fifteen if it's a popular show but it's
it's it's usually cheap it's a good time
and it's always different and you're
almost always guaranteed a big laugh and
even if you're even if it's a show where
it's more tepid and you know there's not
a lot of the big laughs unusual shows
it's still fun like it's still a good
time and I'm still having like a lot of
fun doing it and I enjoy myself while
I'm there and I don't know it's just
like the variety really makes me
interested in it because I don't know
it's just something special about it I
think it's I think it's really good and
I think it like brings a lot to the
table so I I want to go to more improv
theaters and then I want to go to all
the trampoline parks like that's
probably my favorite thing to do now and
I love
do so much of it but I'm going to
trampoline so much because I think it's
fun and it's not gonna do that
I yeah as about it like that's what I
that's what I like to be right now did
the research finish I think the research
finish that about a hundred percent the
research I think it was yeah it finished
okay so god damnit why are these
backwards why did I build this backwards
I don't know no no I built this
backwards oh wait what am i doing oh
yeah it's just freaking it's set up in
the same exact way that I always build
things in the end I didn't do it okay
please prioritize is and actually you
don't need to prioritize that so yeah
that's pretty much that's pretty much
what I get going on right now my
favorite places to go I don't know and
then of course like there's restaurants
and stuff but I don't get out much
I'm a homebody I should get out more
God stop making it out of obsidian clay
if you're watching why why does it
default to the why is obsidian and
wolframite the things that I had the
least of the default things to make
things out of that is just absurd it is
super annoying I don't like it ooh this
alight you can make things out of this
light yeah because I know they got
different I know they got different
material properties like if you make it
out of one thing it has a different
overheat temperature then another thing
and that's really cool and all and I get
it and I love the fact that you do that
but don't default to the most rare
material I just don't wanna I just don't
want that to happen I don't want any
word I'm just gonna go about my way now
okay there we go so now that I got this
yeah gold makes it an overheat less you
know all that jazz okay so I like that
they have different properties that's
cool cuz then you get a choice of what
you make it out of and therefore it has
different properties like I could make
that coal generator out of gold instead
of out of the copper that I did I bet
and then it would overheat less and
that's really cool do I lift oh no no
not anymore really I never really did in
the first place I wasn't a big like
bodybuilder lifter so most of the stuff
that I did was sorry I'm starting to
feel really sick now I'm gonna redo this
because I think I think these are mostly
uh yeah there we go yeah cuz the
materials whoa okay then make this [ __ ]
sandstone and then make the wire have
you wat out of gold
okay there we go I know I could have
probably just over done it over anyway
I'm not gonna go to bed over this legacy
I'm tired buddy I'm gonna go lay down
pretty soon okay huh what don't push
myself I'm not pushing myself that's why
I mean so that's why I'm doing this easy
stream super simple very low stress
stream that's what I like okay no wire
connected to that we don't need we don't
need the big guns we just need this
stuff and then blink okay we got that we
can make the percolators here Cebulski
shabu Ski shabu shabu ski
okay I I I think this is going to make
way too much algae so I'm just gonna I'm
gonna build them I'm gonna build them
and then I'm just gonna make a wait no
hang on because these probably are gonna
overheat and hold on to that thought
wait
okay cuz they make heat not a lot but
enough to warrant making it out of gold
I would have a whole thing in a gold why
not yeah that's a good idea so I'm just
gonna make two of them for now okay
there we go try that one
okay so now that I got that and those
are gonna be those gonna be doing their
thing should have made that out of
Google Dell would make my life a lot
easier
shabu ski Oh someone's working on a shoe
boo ski compilation I saw the progress
you're amazing I forget who it was but
you're amazing thank you okay no liquid
output that's okay I'm gonna build that
because I first need to make a place for
all the slime okay
I thought wolframite was that's a metal
why can I make a pipe out of wolframite
to do anything I thought that was a
metal metal isn't it anyway
yeah how go to sleep soon order give my
mom you can't tell me what to do
I just want to get this dead cuz I want
to see like I've been just dying to see
how this bio distiller works that's all
I really wanted like oh no stress stinky
stress and I only stress stinky Ellie go
get unstressed I've got so much food god
I've got I've never really tried the
Bristol Blair but the Bristol Barry
method before but good god I need more
people in here if I'm gonna have this
much food and I just want to see this
stuff get done so this is only gonna
have a slime about a bloomer
so hopefully we've got a good bit of
slime and I think this is broken I'm
pretty sure this is broken as far as the
last thing I heard but they may have
changed it I don't know I think they put
a patch recently yeah they did change it
okay they didn't change it ah damn it
now it's back to its stupid slow ways ah
they did darn you
darn you so it creates slime is
converted algae a three to one ratio but
it also creates polluted water so that's
fine why is this not made yet there's
nothing unreachable baby's unreachable
well eat a dick it's unreachable [ __ ]
you you're a bag of ass with points that
unreachable it's not reachable eat 10
tits what a bunch of baloney I'm gonna
stab you in the eye I'm gonna eat your
face nice purple gun ooh new arrival can
we get a good one dope all budge oh good
learning but nothing else
all right sure come on ADA
welcome aboard ADA everybody has a new
friend meep go you're not very stressed
but I know you're gonna give yourself in
trouble okay I think I'm gonna
officially transfer over to just bristle
blossoms because I've got tons of Mia
loafs enough to last me like into the
next eternity so I'm gonna go for
blossoms they take forever to start
growing but food obviously is not a
problem right now
food is a wonderful surplus that I've
got and I can always make more food
boxes as needed and sufficient oxygen
generation that's a little low why have
I got polluted oxygen here where's that
coming from
I have a leak I think so
can you why is that unreachable that
makes no sense make it reach it reach in
eyes it reach in eyes it don't don't do
that
that's terrible idea hang on guys I know
I'm haven't talked to you in a while but
I'm just no what's going on with my life
anymore
I don't know who I am anymore let's just
do it
let's just do it fricken the words that
come from bring that water come from
that water come from oh did they put oh
they put they put snow in there didn't
they
goddamn cuz I put a damn liquefiable in
there
I don't feel like unchecking all of
those I don't wanna do that yet Pluta
dice well let's God do that's where it's
coming from what do they have in there
you're not suppose that organic oh god
damn it really none of you were supposed
to have organic not a one of you god
damn it
alright okay oh boy the Frick is
happening there oh that's a frenzy
alright so well we got issues but that's
besides the point
alright these are going how are they
doing and they back to their old shitty
way sure seems like it
yeah okay
seems like it might be a bit more
something than it was before but what is
this pump not pumping goddamn it fill it
fill trade it we need filtration go damn
it I will eat your face there we go
there we go okay now we got it okay so I
think they upped the capability of did
they have the capability of one filter I
don't remember that's producing a lot of
heat produced some corner Berta feet
worked up I don't like that one beefy
bit
I don't like that that's heating up
that's producing a lot of heat I like
that that's a lot of heat I don't know
if is gonna reach an equilibrium it's
like in it the problem is it's like in
an enclosed area so it's not exactly a
lot of airflow here I couldn't make it
right here instead these aren't doing me
a whole lot of good I could
what I can do is I can move this door in
like this well they're gonna go to bed
it's not producing the most seed in the
world but I can use it to my if it's
gonna produce heat it might as well use
it to my advantage since it's always
gonna be running
mmm
mm-hmm okay hang on
I'll figure this problem out what the
hell was it steel door do not translate
I don't know what that means so much to
dig dead there okay that's apparently a
thing it's not getting that hot but it's
still what it's doing is heating up the
area where my crops are and I just can't
have that okay so what I need to do is I
need to
okay so then I'm gonna make two water
purifiers because one pump can feed two
water pure varieties I know that for a
fact - water purifies it let me make
them out of gold
so they don't overheat
okay so what I need to do what I need to
do is I need to re I need to send this
water back without leaking any here yeah
you know what I'm just gonna forget it
it's gonna be fun
there's gonna be fun it's gonna be fun
you're gonna send it this way there we
go there we go sorry for carving writing
it sorry for golfing right in the mic
bow boy okay
then these make amountof guess I can
make them out of gold name the coppers
fine
probably
okay so
I don't think I have pressure
regulations so I'm just gonna send them
out over in there each in each of their
own pipes I don't have any pressure
regulation I don't I know that I don't
okay how are you guys can go to bed
while I'm in the middle of all this
[ __ ] you can do that too that's an
that's an option okay so I'm just going
to get rid of these two hopefully
that'll just fall down there we go
that'll be good enough yeah I can
destroy them all I guess okay
so now they need each their own give
them their own pipes doo doo
Oh someone got the spores oh no I care
[Music]
okay
okay actually know what I'm gonna do is
I'm also going to remake this coal
generator out of gold
whoa ah dammit that was the that was the
contaminated water getting away
I know polluted water got in oh that's
exactly what I didn't want my precious
precious Oh Oh No
I've been screwed I've really boned
myself guys my dudes hmm I've been Oh
Frick me alright almost there just kind
of figure this out so boy so everybody
go you guys forget you guys forget that
you had something to do over here is
that Bob Bob going the goddamn
rejuvenator Bob getting the goddamn
rejuvenator till you better I don't even
know if the rejuvenator cure ism it's
getting there isolate yourself all right
[Music]
where they're not destroying this thing
destroy it
what Oh frickin goddamn it wasn't
pressing the right button that's how big
of an idiot I am
so much cruelty I don't care nope Nadia
here's the stress please thank you good
god oh come on
breathing's for the week now don't run
away I didn't mean it I'm sorry
can you please come back I need water
I really do can you please just finish
this goddamn job okay there now it's
gonna be a gold thing it's gonna be even
better than it was before
and it's not gonna overheat isn't that
right maybe so now we're still probably
gonna need some manual power at some
point here god damn it going to bed
again wait you guys why do you need so
much sleep go to hell well who's just
Ellie and gozman horse who else is
stressed Katherine and she's fine she
can survive
sorry guys this is what happens whenever
I try something that I'm not 100% on
board with is there we go please yes
Wade hurry up hurry up Wade hurry the
freaky freak up okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
come on okay breathing okay and then you
run away what are you gonna do that to
me
there we go make it make it all the way
little more come on me counting on you
counting on you okay all right you big
stupid quitter Katherine's got to do the
job for everybody I ain't that the damn
truth Oh me Pew decide to run over there
where there's no oxygen no you're gonna
do good job look one little thing of
water all right now we got it going cool
okay so now those can produce heat this
can heat up to 125 I don't know if it's
gonna get to 125 let's find out but then
this can produce enough heat so that
these hopefully don't overheat its
rocketing up to 125 isn't it good god
it's in a freezer why does it get so hot
it's in a freezer what
that's so weird it's in a freezer
that's so weird it's literally in a
freezer and that heated up faster than
it did before that's so weird
I can't just constantly feed it
materials like that
Jesus well this is this is a conundrum
that I'll have to there's a conundrum I
have to look at and another day cuz I'm
just I'm not feeling well enough to deal
with it
okay well
all right so anyway this is my base for
now it is the humble beginnings of a
base of base and farm I'm sick I have
the flu so I'm gonna cut this livestream
here thank you everybody for joining me
I hope you enjoyed me just chatting with
you talking about packs and talking
about other stuff I could do I'm gonna
go lay down
I'm very little but I'll be fun I will
survive so hope you guys had a good
night hope you guys have a good night
I'm gonna try to get videos for tomorrow
I just feeling a little off but uh we'll
see what happens
I've already got a video in store so it
should be cool so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
why good night everybody bye bye bye bye
good bye